[Guest] 我们看到一大批软件公司的估值暴跌，因为大家预期 AI 会让软件变成同质化商品。这里有一种可能有点天真的看法，就是：你看，Nvidia 把 GDS2 文件发给 TSMC，TSMC 负责制造逻辑芯片、做交换芯片，然后再和 SK Hynix、Micron、Samsung 生产的 HBM 一起封装。接着再送到台湾的 ODM 那里，由他们把整机柜组装起来。Nvidia 本质上是在做软件，而这些东西是由别人制造的，
We've seen the valuations of a bunch of software companies crash because people are expecting AI to commoditize software. There's a potentially naive way of thinking about things, which is: look, Nvidia sends a GDS2 file to TSMC. TSMC builds the logic dies, it builds the switches, then it packages them with the HBM that SK Hynix, Micron, and Samsung make. Then it sends it to an ODM in Taiwan where they assemble the racks. Nvidia is fundamentally making software that
[Guest] 那如果软件变成了同质化商品，Nvidia 会不会也被同质化？归根结底，总得有东西把电子转化成 token。把电子转化成 token 这件事，
other people are manufacturing, and if software gets commoditized, does Nvidia get commoditized? In the end, something has to transform electrons to tokens. The transformation of electrons to tokens
[Guest] 以及随着时间推移让这些 token 变得更有价值，是很难被彻底同质化的。从电子到 token 的转化，是一段极其惊人的旅程。制造一个 token，就像让一个分子比另一个分子更有价值一样，也是在让
and making those tokens more valuable over time is hard to completely commoditize. The transformation from electrons to tokens is such an incredible journey. Making that token is like making one molecule more valuable than another molecule, making
[Guest] 一个 token 比另一个 token 更有价值。为了让这个 token 有价值，背后投入的艺术性、工程能力、科学研究和发明创造是巨大的。显然，我们正在实时见证这一切的发生。这里面的转化过程、制造过程，以及背后的所有科学，远远谈不上被充分理解，而这段旅程也远未结束。
one token more valuable than another. The amount of artistry, engineering, science, and invention that goes into making that token valuable, obviously we're watching it happen in real time. The transformation, the manufacturing, all of the science that goes in there is far from deeply understood and the journey is far from over.
[Guest] 我怀疑那种情况不会发生。当然，我们会把它做得更高效。你刚才提问的方式，其实就是我对我们公司的心智模型。输入是电子，输出是 token，中间是 Nvidia。我们的工作，就是为了实现这种转化，尽可能多做必要的事，同时尽可能少做不必要的事，
I doubt that it will happen. We're going to make it more efficient, of course. The way that you framed the question is my mental model of our company. The input is electrons, the output is tokens. In the middle is Nvidia. Our job is to do as much as necessary and as little as possible to enable that transformation
[Guest] 从而让这种转化具备惊人的能力。我说的“尽可能少做”，意思是，凡是我不必亲自做的，我就和别人合作，把它纳入我的生态系统。你如果看今天的 Nvidia，我们可能拥有规模最大的合作伙伴生态之一，上下游供应链、各类计算机公司、应用开发者、模型开发者都在其中。AI 如果要打个比方，就像一个五层蛋糕。
to be done at incredible capabilities. What I mean by "as little as possible," whatever I don't need to do, I partner with somebody and make it part of my ecosystem. If you look at Nvidia today, we probably have the largest ecosystem of partners, both in the supply chain upstream and downstream, all of the computer companies, application developers, and model makers. AI is a five-layer cake, if you will.
[Guest] 我们在这五层的每一层都有生态。我们尽量少做，但事实证明，那些我们必须做的部分，难度高得离谱。我不认为那会被同质化。事实上，我也不认为企业软件公司、工具厂商会被同质化……如今大多数软件公司其实都是工具厂商。
We have ecosystems across the entire five layers. We try to do as little as possible, but the part that we have to do, as it turns out, is insanely hard. I don't think that gets commoditized. In fact, I also don't think the enterprise software companies, the tools makers… Most software companies today are tool makers.
[Guest] 当然也有些不是。有些公司做的是把工作流程固化成系统。但对很多公司来说，它们本质上还是工具厂商。比如说，Excel 是工具，PowerPoint 是工具，Cadence 做的是工具，Synopsys 做的也是工具。其实我的看法和很多人正好相反。我认为 agent 的数量会呈指数级增长，而……
Some of them are not. Some of them are workflow codification systems. But for a lot of companies, they're tool makers. For example, Excel is a tool, PowerPoint is a tool, Cadence makes tools, Synopsys makes tools. I actually see the opposite of what people see. I think the number of agents is going to grow exponentially, and the number
[Guest] 工具使用者的数量会呈指数级增长。非常有可能，这些工具的实例数量都会暴涨。Synopsys Design Compiler 的实例数量很可能会暴涨，同时，使用 floor planner、我们的版图工具以及设计规则检查器的 agent 数量也会激增。
of tool users is going to grow exponentially. It's very likely that the number of instances of all these tools is going to skyrocket. It’s very likely that the number of instances of Synopsys Design Compiler is going to skyrocket, along with the number of agents using the floor planners, our layout tools, and our design rule checkers.
[Guest] 今天我们的限制在于工程师数量。明天，这些工程师会有一大批 agent 来辅助。我们会以前所未有的方式探索设计空间，而且我们会继续使用今天就在用的这些工具。我觉得，工具使用会让这些软件公司迎来爆发式增长。之所以还没发生，是因为 agent 现在还不够擅长使用这些工具。要么这些公司自己把 agent 做出来，要么 agent 会进步到足以熟练使用这些工具。
Today we're limited by the number of engineers. Tomorrow, those engineers are going to be supported by a bunch of agents. We're going to be exploring the design space like you've never seen before, and we're going to use the tools that we use today. I think tool use is going to cause the software companies to skyrocket. The reason why it hasn't happened yet is because the agents aren't good enough at using their tools yet. Either these companies are going to build the agents themselves, or agents are going to get good enough to be able to use those tools.
[Host] 我觉得会是两者结合。你们最新的文件里，我记得你们对晶圆厂、内存和封装方面的采购承诺已经接近 1000 亿美元。SemiAnalysis 报道说，你们这类采购承诺会达到 2500 亿美元。一种解读是，Nvidia 真正的护城河在于，你们已经锁定了未来很多年这些稀缺组件的供应。别人也许能做出加速器，
I think it's going to be a combination of both. I think in your latest filings, you had almost a $100 billion in purchase commitments with foundries, memory, and packaging. SemiAnalysis has reported that you will have $250 billion of these kinds of purchase commitments. One interpretation is that Nvidia's moat is really that you've locked up many years of these scarce components. Somebody else might have an accelerator,
[Host] 但他们真的拿得到内存来造吗？真的拿得到逻辑芯片来造吗？这会不会才是 Nvidia 未来几年的核心护城河？这是我们能做到、但别人很难做到的事情之一。我们在上游做了非常巨大的投入承诺。有些是明确的，也就是你刚提到的这些承诺。有些则是隐性的。比如说，上游的很多投资其实是由
but can they actually get the memory to build it? Can they actually get the logic to build it? Is this really Nvidia's big moat for the next few years? It's one of the things that we can do that is hard for someone else to do. We've made enormous commitments upstream. Some of it is explicit, these commitments that you mentioned. Some of it is implicit. For example, a lot of the investments that are upstream are made by
[Guest] 我们的供应链来做的，因为我会对那些 CEO 说："我来告诉你这个行业会变得多大，我来解释为什么会这样，我来和你一起把这件事推演清楚，也让你看看我所看到的东西。" 正因为有了这样一个向各个上游行业 CEO 传递信息、激发信心并达成一致的过程，他们才愿意做这些投资。他们为什么愿意为我投资，而不是为别人投资？
our supply chain because I said to the CEOs, "Let me tell you how big this industry is going to be, let me explain to you why, let me reason through it with you, and let me show you what I see." As a result of that process of informing, inspiring, and aligning with CEOs of all different industries upstream, they're willing to make the investments. Why are they willing to make the investments for me and not someone else?
[Guest] 原因就在于，他们知道我有能力买下他们的供给，并通过我的下游把它卖出去。事实是，Nvidia 的下游供应链和我们的下游需求规模都非常大，所以他们愿意在上游进行投资。如果你去看 GTC，大家都会惊叹它的规模，以及来参加的人。
The reason for that is because they know that I have the capacity to buy their supply and sell it through my downstream. The fact is that Nvidia's downstream supply chain and our downstream demand is so large, they're willing to make the investment upstream. If you look at GTC, people are marveled by the scale of it and the people that go.
[Guest] 那是一个完整的 360 度全景，整个 AI 宇宙都汇聚在一个地方。他们之所以都在同一个地方，是因为他们需要彼此见面。我把他们聚在一起，这样下游能看到上游，上游能看到下游，而且所有人都能看到 AI 的进展。更重要的是，他们都能见到 AI 原生公司，见到所有正在被打造出来的 AI 初创公司，以及所有正在发生的惊人成果，这样他们就能亲眼看到我一直在告诉他们的那些事情。
It's a full 360 degrees, the entire universe of AI all in one place. They're all in one place because they need to see each other. I bring them together so that the downstream can see the upstream, the upstream can see the downstream, and all of them can see the advances in AI. Very importantly, they can all meet the AI natives, all the AI startups being built, and all the amazing things happening so they can see firsthand all the things that I tell them.
[Guest] 我花了很多时间，直接或间接地向我们的供应链、合作伙伴和生态系统传递摆在我们面前的机会。总有人会说："Jensen，你的大多数主题演讲里，总是一个发布接着一个发布。" 而我们的主题演讲里，总会有一部分
I spend a lot of my time informing, directly or indirectly, our supply chain, partners, and ecosystem about the opportunity in front of us. Some people always say, "Jensen, in most keynotes, it's one announcement after another." With our keynotes, there’s always a part
[Guest] 这里面有一部分会让人有点痛苦，因为它几乎听起来像是在做教育。其实，这正是我现在在想的事。我得确保整个供应链——上游、下游，以及整个生态——都明白，接下来会有什么扑面而来，为什么会来，什么时候来，规模会有多大，并且能够像我一样系统性地去理解这件事。
of it that's a little torturous in the sense that it almost comes across like education. In fact, that's exactly on my mind. I need to make sure the entire supply chain, upstream and downstream, the ecosystem, understands what is coming at us, why it's coming, when it's coming, how big it's going to be, and is able to reason about it systematically,
[Guest] 就像我理解它那样。至于你说的护城河，我们之所以能建立起来，是因为我们能够为未来做建设。如果未来几年我们的规模会到一万亿美元，那我们有相应的供应链去支撑。没有我们的覆盖范围、没有我们业务运转的速度……就像有现金流一样，也有供应链流动，也有周转。
just like I reason about it. Regarding the moat as you describe it, we're able to build for a future. If our next several years are a trillion dollars in scale, we have the supply chain to do it. Without our reach, the velocity of our business… Just as there's cash flow, there's supply chain flow, there's churns.
[Host] 如果业务周转不高，没有人会为一种架构去搭建供应链。我们之所以能维持这样的规模，唯一的原因就是下游需求实在太大了。大家看得到，听得到，也看得出这一切正在到来。这让我们能够以现在这样的规模去做我们正在做的事。不过我确实想更具体地了解，上游到底能不能跟上。
Nobody is going to build a supply chain for an architecture if the business churns are low. Our ability to sustain the scale is only because our downstream demand is so great. And they see it, they hear about it, they see it all coming. That allows us to do the things we're able to do at the scale we do them. I do want to understand more concretely whether the upstream can keep up.
[Host] 这些年来，你们的营收一直在年同比翻倍。你们向全世界提供的 flops 数量，年同比甚至增长了三倍以上。而且在现在这种体量下还能做到 2 倍增长，真的非常惊人。没错。但再看逻辑制程这边，你们是 TSMC N3 节点最大的客户，也是 N2 上最大的客户之一。根据 SemiAnalysis 的说法，今年整个 AI 会占到 N3 的 60%，明年会到 86%。
For many years now, you guys have been 2x-ing revenue year over year. You've been more than tripling the amount of flops you're providing to the world year over year. And 2x-ing at this scale now is really incredible. Exactly. But then you look at logic. You're the biggest customer on TSMC's N3 node, and you're one of the biggest on N2. AI as a whole this year is going to be sixty percent of N3. It's going to be 86% next year, according to SemiAnalysis.
[Host] 当你已经占了大头，还怎么翻倍？而且还要年复一年地翻倍？我们现在是不是进入了这样一个阶段：AI 算力的增长率必须因为上游供给而放缓？你觉得有办法绕过去吗？归根结底，我们要怎么做到晶圆厂产能年复一年地再翻一倍？从某种层面上说，
How do you double if you're the majority? And how do you do that year over year? Are we in a regime now where the growth rate in AI compute has to slow because of upstream? Do you see a way to get around this? How do we build 2x more fabs year over year, ultimately? At some level,
[Guest] 在任何一个时点上，全球的即时需求都大于上下游的供给。在任何时刻，我们甚至可能受限于水管工的人数，这种情况真的发生过。顺便说一句，明年的 GTC 应该请水管工来。这个主意其实很棒。不过这是一个很好的
the instantaneous demand is greater than the supply upstream and downstream in the world. At any instant, we could be limited by the number of plumbers, which actually happens. The plumbers are invited to next year's GTC. By the way, great idea. But that's a good
[Guest] 状态。你会希望一个行业的即时需求大于整个行业的总供给。反过来显然就没那么好了。如果两边差得太远，如果某个特定环节掉队太多，整个行业就会一窝蜂地扑上去补它。比如说，你注意到现在大家已经不怎么谈 CoWoS 了。
condition. You want an industry where the instantaneous demand is greater than the total supply of the industry. The opposite is obviously less good. If we're too far apart, if one particular component is too far away, the industry swarms it. For example, notice people aren't talking very much about CoWoS anymore.
[Guest] 原因就在于，过去两年我们对它进行了极其猛烈的投入。翻倍、翻倍、再翻倍，叠了好几轮翻倍。现在我觉得我们的状况已经相当不错了。TSMC 现在也知道，CoWoS 的供应必须跟上其他逻辑需求以及内存需求。他们正在以扩张逻辑产能同样的力度，去扩张 CoWoS 和未来的先进封装技术。
The reason for that is because for two years we swarmed the living daylights out of it. We doubled, doubled, doubled on several doubles. Now I think we're in fairly good shape. TSMC now knows that CoWoS supply has to keep up with the rest of the logic demand and the memory demand. They're scaling CoWoS and future packaging technologies at the same level as they scale logic.
[Guest] 这太棒了，因为很长一段时间里，CoWoS 和 HBM memory 都还算是比较小众、偏专用的东西。但现在它们已经不再是小众技术了。大家现在都意识到，它们是主流计算技术。当然，这也让我们现在更有能力去影响供应链中更大范围的环节。在 AI 革命刚开始的时候，这些我现在说的话，其实五年前我就在说了。
This is terrific, because for a long time, CoWoS and HBM memory were rather specialty. But they're not specialties anymore. People now realize they're mainstream computing technology. Of course, we're now much more able to influence a larger scope of our supply chain. At the beginning of the AI revolution, all the things
[Guest] 当时有些人相信这件事，也为此投入了资源，比如 Sanjay 和 Micron 团队。我到现在还很清楚地记得那次会议，当时我非常明确地讲了接下来会发生什么、为什么会发生，以及今天这些局面的预测。他们后来确实重注押上去了。
that I say now, I was saying five years ago. Some people believed in it and invested in it, for example, Sanjay and the Micron team. I still remember the meeting really well where I was clear about exactly what was going to happen, why it was going to happen, and the predictions of today. They really doubled down on it.
[Guest] 我们和他们在 LPDDR 和 HBM memories 上都展开了合作，他们也确实投入很大。这显然给公司带来了巨大的收益。有些人进场得稍微晚一点，但现在大家都来了。这里面的每一个瓶颈都得到了高度关注。现在我们已经会提前好几年预判这些瓶颈。
We partnered with them across LPDDR and HBM memories, and they really invested in it. It obviously has been tremendous for the company. Some people came a little bit later, but now they're all here. Each one of these bottlenecks gets a great deal of attention. Now we're prefetching the bottlenecks years in advance.
[Guest] 比如说，过去几年我们和 Lumentum、Coherent 以及整个 silicon photonics 生态所做的投资，确实重塑了供应链。我们围绕 TSMC 搭建起了一整套供应链。我们和他们在 COUPE 上合作，发明了很多技术，并把这些专利授权给供应链里的伙伴，好让整个体系保持开放。
For example, the investments that we've done with Lumentum, Coherent, and the silicon photonics ecosystem over the last several years really reshaped the supply chain. We built up an entire supply chain around TSMC. We partnered with them on COUPE, invented a whole bunch of technology, and licensed those patents to the supply chain to keep it nice and open.
[Guest] 我们正在通过发明新技术、新工作流、新测试设备（比如双面探测），以及投资公司、帮助它们扩大产能，来为供应链做准备。你可以看到，我们是在努力塑造整个生态，让供应链能够支撑这样的规模。看起来有些瓶颈比另一些更容易解决。扩大 CoWoS 产能，对比扩大——顺便说一句，我刚刚直接跳到最难的那个了。
We're preparing the supply chain through the invention of new technologies, new workflows, new testing equipment like double-sided probing, investing in companies, and helping them scale up their capacity. You can see that we're trying to shape the ecosystem so that the supply chain is ready to support the scale. It seems like some bottlenecks are easier than others. Scaling up CoWoS versus scaling up— I went to the hardest one, by the way.
[Guest] 是什么？水管工。水管工和电工。这也是我对那些“末日派”说工作将终结、岗位会消失的一大担忧之一。如果我们劝大家不要去做 software engineers，
Which is? Plumbers. Plumbers and electricians. This is one of the concerns that I have about the doomers describing the end of work and killing of jobs. If we discourage people from being software engineers,
[Guest] 那我们最后就真的会缺 software engineers。十年前也出现过同样的预测。有些“末日派”当时告诉大家：“不管怎样，千万别去当 radiologist。”你现在可能还能在网上看到一些那样的视频，说 radiology 会是第一个消失的职业，世界将不再需要更多 radiologists。结果我们现在最缺的是什么？Radiologists。回到刚才这个点，有些东西你确实可以扩产，而另一些……
we're going to run out of software engineers. The same prediction happened ten years ago. Some of the doomers were telling people, "Whatever you do, don't be a radiologist." You might hear some of those videos still on the web saying radiology is going to be the first career to go and the world is not going to need any more radiologists. Guess what we're short of? Radiologists. Going back to this point about how some things you
[Guest] 你到底要怎么做到一年制造出 2 倍的 logic？归根结底，memory 和 logic 的瓶颈都在 EUV。你怎么才能做到 EUV machines 的年产量逐年翻倍？这些都不是不能快速扩张的事。所有这些其实都可以在两三年内做到。你只需要一个明确的需求信号。一旦你能造出一台，你就能造十台；一旦你能造出十台，你就能造出一百万台。
can scale, and other things… How do you actually manufacture 2x the amount of logic a year? Ultimately, memory and logic are bottlenecked by EUV. How do you get to 2x as many EUV machines year over year? None of that is impossible to scale quickly. All of that is easy to do within two or three years. You just need a demand signal. Once you can build one, you can build ten, and once you can build ten, you can build a million.
[Host] 这些东西并不难复制。你会把布局做到供应链的多下游？你会去找 ASML 说：“如果我往后三年看，Nvidia 要做到每年两万亿美元营收，我们就需要多得多的 EUV 光刻机”吗？有些环节我得直接去推动，有些是间接推动，还有一些……如果我能说服 TSMC，ASML 自然也会被说服。我们必须盯住那些关键卡点。
These things are not hard to replicate. How far down the supply chain do you go? Do you go to ASML and say, "Hey, if I look out three years from now, for Nvidia to be generating two trillion a year in revenue, we need way more EUV machines"? Some of them I have to directly, some of them indirectly, and some of them… If I can convince TSMC, ASML will be convinced. We have to think about the critical pinch points.
[Guest] 但如果 TSMC 被说服了，几年之后你就会有足够多的 EUV 光刻机。我的意思是，这些瓶颈没有一个会持续超过几年，也就是两三年，没有一个会。与此同时，我们还在把计算效率提升 10 倍、20 倍，而从 Hopper 到 Blackwell，提升幅度甚至有 30 倍到 50 倍。因为 CUDA 非常灵活，我们也在不断提出新的算法。
But if TSMC is convinced, you'll have plenty of EUV machines in a few years. My point is that none of the bottlenecks last longer than a couple of years, two, three years, none of them. Meanwhile, we're improving computing efficiency by 10x 20x, and in the case of Hopper to Blackwell, 30x to 50x. We're coming up with new algorithms because CUDA is so flexible.
[Guest] 我们还在开发各种新技术，不只是扩产，也在持续提升效率。这些事情我都不担心。我担心的是我们下游的那些问题。比如限制能源发展的政策……没有能源，你就不可能建立一个产业。没有能源，你也不可能建立一个全新的制造业。我们想让美国再工业化。
We're developing all kinds of new techniques so that we drive efficiency in addition to increasing capacity. None of those things worry me. It's the stuff that's downstream from us. Energy policies that prevent energy from… You can't create an industry without energy. You can't create a whole new manufacturing industry without energy. We want to reindustrialize the United States.
[Host] 我们想把芯片制造、计算机制造和封装带回美国。我们想建设像 EV、机器人这样的新产业。我们还想建 AI 工厂。没有能源，这些东西一个都建不起来，而且这些事都需要很长时间。增加芯片产能，那是个 2 到 3 年的问题。增加 CoWoS 产能，也是个 2 到 3 年的问题。有意思。我感觉有时候我请来的嘉宾会跟我说完全相反的话。这个问题上，我确实没有足够的技术知识来判断谁对谁错。妙就妙在，你现在问的正是这方面的专家。
We want to bring back chip manufacturing, computer manufacturing, and packaging. We want to build new things like EVs and robots. We want to build AI factories. You can't build any of these things without energy, and those things take a long time. More chip capacity, that's a 2-3 year problem. More CoWoS capacity, 2-3 year problem. Interesting. I feel like I have guests tell me the exact opposite thing sometimes. In this case, I just don't have the technical knowledge to adjudicate. The beautiful thing is you're talking to the expert.
[Host] 这倒是。我想问问你的竞争对手。如果看 TPU，可以说全球前三的大模型里，至少有两个——Claude 和 Gemini——是用 TPU 训练出来的。这对 Nvidia 未来意味着什么？我们做的是非常不一样的东西。
True. I want to ask about your competitors. If you look at the TPU, arguably two out of the top three models in the world, Claude and Gemini, were trained on TPU. What does that mean for Nvidia going forward? We build a very different thing.
[Guest] Nvidia 做出来的是加速计算，不是张量处理单元。加速计算可以用于各种各样的事情：分子动力学、量子色动力学、数据处理、数据框架、结构化数据，以及非结构化数据。它也可以用于流体力学和粒子物理。
What Nvidia built is accelerated computing, not a tensor processing unit. Accelerated computing is used for all kinds of things: molecular dynamics, quantum chromodynamics, data processing, data frames, structured data, and unstructured data. It's also used for fluid dynamics and particle physics.
[Guest] 除此之外，我们当然也把它用于 AI。加速计算的应用面要广泛得多。虽然今天大家都在谈 AI，而且它显然非常重要、影响也非常大，但计算本身远不止这些。Nvidia 重新定义了计算的方式，把它从通用计算推进到了加速计算。
In addition, we use it for AI. Accelerated computing is much more diverse. Although AI is the conversation today and is obviously very important and impactful, computing is much broader than that. Nvidia has reinvented the way computing is done, moving from general-purpose computing to accelerated computing.
[Guest] 我们的市场覆盖范围，远远不是任何 TPU 或 ASIC 能达到的。如果看我们的定位，我们是唯一一家能为各种类型应用提供加速的公司。我们有一个庞大的生态系统，所以各种框架和算法都能跑在 Nvidia 上。
Our market reach is far greater than any TPU or ASIC can possibly have. If you look at our position, we're the only company that accelerates applications of all kinds. We have a gigantic ecosystem. So all kinds of frameworks and algorithms run on Nvidia.
[Guest] 因为我们的计算机从设计之初就是给别人来运营的，所以任何做运营的人都可以买我们的系统。大多数这类自建系统，你都得自己当操作员，因为它们从来就没被设计得足够灵活，没法让别人来操作。正因为任何人都能运营我们的系统，我们才进入了所有云平台，包括 Google、Amazon、Azure 和 OCI。
Because our computers are designed to be operated by other people, anyone who's an operator can buy our systems. With most of these home-built systems, you have to be your own operator because they were never designed to be flexible enough for others to operate. Because anybody can operate our systems, we're in every cloud, including Google, Amazon, Azure, and OCI.
[Guest] 如果你想把它运营起来对外出租，那你最好得有一个庞大的客户生态，覆盖很多行业，来承接这些算力。如果你想自己运营，我们显然也有能力帮助你自己把它跑起来，就像我们给 Elon 的 xAI 做的那样。
If you want to operate it to rent, you better have a large ecosystem of customers in many industries to be the offtakers. If you want to operate it for yourself, we obviously have the ability to help you operate it yourself, like we did for Elon with xAI.
[Guest] 而且因为我们能让任何公司、任何行业的运营团队都用起来，你也可以拿它来打造一台超级计算机，用于 Lilly 的科研和药物发现。我们可以帮助他们运营自己的超级计算机，并把它用于我们所加速的整个药物发现和生物科学的广泛场景。
And because we can enable operators in any company and any industry, you could use it to build a supercomputer for scientific research and drug discovery at Lilly. We can help them operate their own supercomputer and use it for the entire diversity of drug discovery and biological sciences that we accelerate.
[Guest] 我们能覆盖的应用场景有一大堆，是 TPU 做不了的。Nvidia 打造 CUDA，不只是为了做一个出色的张量处理单元，它还能覆盖数据处理、计算、AI 等等的整个生命周期。我们的市场机会就是大得多，覆盖范围也广得多。
There are just a whole bunch of applications that we can address that you can't do with TPUs. Nvidia built CUDA to be a fantastic tensor processing unit as well, but it also handles every life cycle of data processing, computing, AI, and so on. Our market opportunity is just a lot larger, and our reach is a lot greater.
[Host] 因为我们现在支持世界上所有应用，你可以在任何地方部署 Nvidia 系统，而且知道一定会有客户买单。这是完全不同的一件事。这个问题会有点长。你们的营收非常惊人，而你们并不是靠医药和量子计算每个季度赚 600 亿美元。你们之所以能做到，是因为 AI 是一项前所未有、而且正以前所未有速度增长的技术。
Because we support every application in the world now, you can build Nvidia systems anywhere and know that there will be customers for it. It's a very different thing. This is going to be a long question. You have spectacular revenue, and you're not making $60 billion a quarter from pharma and quantum. You're making it because AI is an unprecedented technology that is growing unprecedentedly fast.
[Host] 那问题就是，对 AI 本身来说，什么才是最优的。我不是做底层细节的，但我会和一些做 AI 研究的朋友聊天，他们会说：“你看，我用 TPU 的时候，它就是一个巨大的脉动阵列，特别适合做矩阵乘法；而 GPU 非常灵活。遇到大量分支或者不规则内存访问时，它就特别好用。”但 AI 是什么？不就是一遍又一遍、可预测性很强的矩阵乘法吗。你根本不需要牺牲任何芯片面积
The question then is what is best for AI specifically. I'm not in the details, but I talk to my AI researcher friends and they say, "Look, when I use a TPU, it's this big systolic array that's perfect for doing matrix multiplies, whereas a GPU is very flexible. It's great when you have lots of branching or irregular memory access." But what is AI? It's just these very predictable matrix multiplies again and again and again. You don't have to give up any die area
[Host] 去放 warp 调度器，或者在线程和内存 bank 之间做切换的那些东西。而 TPU 恰恰是为当下正在上线的这波计算需求——也就是带来大部分营收增长和使用场景增长的那部分——做了高度优化。我很好奇你怎么看。矩阵乘法确实是 AI 的重要组成部分，但它不是全部。
for warp schedulers or switches between threads and memory banks. And the TPU is really optimized for the bulk of this growth in revenue and use case for compute that is coming online right now. I wonder how you react to that. Matrix multiplies are an important part of AI, but they're not the only part.
[Guest] 如果你想提出一种新的 attention 机制，用不同方式做解耦，或者干脆发明一种全新的架构——比如混合型 SSM——那你需要的是一种通用可编程的架构。如果你想做一个把 diffusion 和 autoregressive 技术融合起来的模型，你需要的也还是一种通用可编程的架构。
If you want to come up with a new attention mechanism, disaggregate in a different way, or invent a whole new type of architecture altogether—like a hybrid SSM—you want an architecture that's generally programmable. If you want to create a model that fuses diffusion and autoregressive techniques, you want an architecture that’s just generally programmable.
[Guest] 我们什么都能跑，你能想到的基本都可以。这就是优势所在。因为这是一个可编程系统，所以发明新算法会容易得多。而能够发明新算法，才是真正让 AI 进步这么快的原因。TPU 和其他东西一样，也会受到 Moore's Law 的影响，也就是我们知道的——
We run everything you can imagine. That's the advantage. It allows for the invention of new algorithms a lot more easily, because it's a programmable system. The ability to invent new algorithms is really what makes AI advance so quickly. TPUs, like anything else, are impacted by Moore's Law, which
[Guest] 每年大概提升 25%。如果真想实现 10 倍、100 倍这种飞跃，唯一的办法就是每年都从根本上改变算法，以及它的计算方式。这就是 Nvidia 的核心优势。我们之所以能把 Blackwell 相比 Hopper 做到 50 倍提升，唯一的原因就是这个。当我——
we know is increasing by about 25% per year. The only way to really get 10x or 100x leaps is to fundamentally change the algorithm and how it's computed every single year. That's Nvidia's fundamental advantage. The only reason we were able to make Blackwell to Hopper 50x… When I
[Guest] 第一次宣布 Blackwell 的能效会比 Hopper 高 35 倍时，没人相信。后来 Dylan 写了篇文章，说我其实还保守了，实际是 50 倍。光靠 Moore's Law，你不可能合理地做到这一点。我们解决这个问题的方式，是用新的模型，比如 MoE，这些模型会被并行化、解耦化，
first announced Blackwell was going to be 35x more energy efficient than Hopper, nobody believed it. Then Dylan wrote an article saying I sandbagged, and it's actually fifty times. You can't reasonably do that with just Moore's Law. The way we solve that problem is with new models, like MoEs, that are parallelized, disaggregated,
[Guest] 并分布到整个计算系统中去执行。如果没有能力真正深入到底层，用 CUDA 搞出新的 kernel，这件事就会非常难做。关键在于两者的结合：一方面是我们架构的可编程性，另一方面是 Nvidia 是一家极度强调协同设计的公司。我们甚至可以把一部分——
and distributed across a computing system. Without the ability to really get down and come up with new kernels with CUDA, it's really hard to do. It's the combination of the programmability of our architecture and the fact that Nvidia is an extreme co-design company. We can even offload some of the
[Guest] 计算卸载到互连本身里，比如 NVLink，或者卸载到网络里，比如 Spectrum-X。我们可以同时在处理器、系统、互连、库以及算法这些层面一起做改动。没有 CUDA 来实现这些，我甚至都不知道该从哪开始。我的赞助商 Crusoe 是最早提供 NVIDIA Blackwell 和 Blackwell Ultra 平台的云服务商之一。
computation into the fabric itself, like NVLink, or into the network with Spectrum-X. We could affect change across the processors, the system, the fabric, the libraries, and the algorithm simultaneously. Without CUDA to do that, I wouldn't even know where to start. My sponsor Crusoe was among the first clouds to offer NVIDIA’s Blackwell and Blackwell Ultra platforms.
[Host] 而且他们刚刚宣布，计划在今年晚些时候部署 NVIDIA Vera Rubin。但能用上最先进的硬件，只是故事的一部分。比如，大多数推理引擎已经会对单个用户的前向传递做 KV cache 了。但 Crusoe 是跨用户、跨 GPU 来做这件事的。所以如果有一千个 agent 在跑同一个 system prompt，Crusoe 只需要计算一次 KV cache，整个集群里的每一块 GPU 都能直接用上。随着系统越来越 agentic，而且为了调用工具、访问文件而需要更长的前缀，这一点就尤其重要。
And they just announced their NVIDIA Vera Rubin deployment scheduled for later this year. But access to state-of-the-art hardware is only part of the story. For example, most inference engines already do KV caching for a single user's forward passes. But Crusoe does it across users and GPUs. So if a thousand agents are running on the same system prompt, Crusoe only has to compute the KV cache once for it to become available to every single GPU in the cluster. This is especially important as systems get more agentic and require much longer prefixes in order to use tools and access files.
[Host] 在最近的一项基准测试中，Crusoe 的首 token 时间最快可比 vLLM 快 10 倍，吞吐量最高可提升 5 倍。这只是你应该用 Crusoe 跑推理负载的众多理由之一。如果你训练也需要 GPU，那也不用切换云平台。Crusoe 这方面也能满足你。去 crusoe.ai/dwarkesh 了解更多。这也引出了一个很有意思的问题，就是——
In a recent benchmark, Crusoe was able to deliver up to 10x faster time-to-first token and up to 5x better throughput than vLLM. This is just one among many reasons that you should run your inference workload with Crusoe. And if you need GPUs for training, you don't need to switch clouds. Crusoe's got you covered there too. Go to crusoe.ai/dwarkesh to learn more. This gets at an interesting question about
[Host] Nvidia 的客户结构。你们 60% 的收入来自这五大 hyperscaler。在另一个时代、面对另一类客户——比如做实验的教授——他们需要的是 CUDA。他们没法用别的加速器。他们只需要用 CUDA 跑 PyTorch，并且让一切都优化好。但这些 hyperscaler 有资源自己写 kernel。事实上，他们为了拿到那种——
Nvidia's clientele. 60% of your revenue is coming from these big five hyperscalers. In a different era with different customers—let's say professors running experiments—they need CUDA. They can't use another accelerator. They just needed to run PyTorch with CUDA and have everything optimized. But these hyperscalers have the resources to write their own kernels. In fact, they have to in order to get that
[Host] 他们需要为自己特定架构榨出最后 5% 的性能。Anthropic 和 Google 大多都在跑自己的加速器，或者用 TPU 和 Trainium。但就连使用 GPU 的 OpenAI，也有 Triton，因为他们需要自己的 kernel。甚至一路下探到 CUDA C++，不再用 cuBLAS 和 NCCL，而是有自己的一整套栈，
last 5% of performance they need for their specific architecture. Anthropic and Google are mostly running their own accelerators or running TPUs and Trainium. But even OpenAI, using GPUs, has Triton because they need their own kernels. Down to CUDA C++, instead of using cuBLAS and NCCL, they've got their own stack which
[Host] 而且还能编译到其他加速器上。如果你的大多数客户都能、也确实会替换掉 CUDA，那 CUDA 到底在多大程度上，真的是让 Nvidia 上的前沿 AI 成立的关键？CUDA 是一个非常丰富的生态。如果你想先在某种计算平台上构建，优先基于 CUDA 来做是非常聪明的。
compiles to other accelerators as well. If most of your customers can and do make replacements for CUDA, to what extent is CUDA really the thing that is going to make frontier AI happen on Nvidia? CUDA is a rich ecosystem. If you want to build on any computer first, building on CUDA first is incredibly smart.
[Guest] 正因为这个生态非常丰富，我们支持所有框架。如果你想写自定义 kernel……比如说，我们对 Triton 的贡献就非常大。所以 Triton 的后端里有大量 Nvidia 的技术。我们很乐意帮助每一个框架做到它所能达到的最好。有非常非常多的框架，像 Triton、vLLM、SGLang 等等。
Because the ecosystem is so rich, we support every framework. If you want to create custom kernels… For example, we contribute enormously to Triton. So the back end of Triton has huge amounts of Nvidia technology. We're delighted to help every framework become as great as it can be. There are lots and lots of frameworks. There's Triton, vLLM, SGLang, and more.
[Guest] 现在又冒出来一大批新的强化学习框架，比如 verl 和 NeMo RL。随着后训练和强化学习的发展，整个领域都在爆发式增长。所以如果你想基于某种架构来构建，基于 CUDA 是最合理的，因为你知道这个生态很强大。你也知道，如果出了什么问题，更有可能是在你的代码里，
Now there's a whole bunch of new reinforcement learning frameworks coming out, like verl and NeMo RL. With post-training and reinforcement learning, that entire area is just exploding. So if you want to build on an architecture, building on CUDA makes the most sense because you know the ecosystem is great. You know that if something happens, it's more likely in your code and
[Guest] 而不是在底下那一大堆代码里。别忘了，构建这些系统时你要面对的代码量有多大。出了问题的时候，到底是你写错了，还是计算机出了问题？你当然希望永远是前者，也就是你能信任这台计算机。显然，我们自己也还是有很多 bug，但我们的系统已经被反复打磨得非常成熟了，至少你可以放心在这个基础之上继续构建。这是第一点：生态的丰富性、可编程性和能力。
not in the mountain of code underneath. Don't forget the amount of code you're dealing with when building these systems. When something doesn't work, was it you or was it the computer? You would like it to always be you and to be able to trust the computer. Obviously, we still have lots of bugs ourselves, but our system is so well wrung out that you can at least build on top of the foundation. That's number one: the richness, programmability, and capability of the ecosystem.
[Guest] 第二点是，如果你是开发者，不管你在做什么，你最看重的一件事就是装机量。你希望你写的软件能跑在大量其他计算机上。你写软件不是只给自己用的。你是为自己的集群，或者别人的集群写的，因为你是框架开发者。Nvidia 的 CUDA 生态，归根结底就是它最宝贵的财富。
The second thing is, if you're a developer building anything at all, the single most important thing you want is an install base. You want the software you write to run on a whole bunch of other computers. You're not building software just for yourself. You're building it for your fleet or everybody else's fleet because you're a framework builder. Nvidia's CUDA ecosystem is ultimately its great treasure.
[Guest] 我们现在外面已经有几亿块 GPU 了。每一家云厂商都有。往前可以追溯到 A10、A100、H100、H200，还有 L 系列、P 系列，种类非常多。它们有各种各样的规格和形态。如果你是一家机器人公司，你会希望这套
We have several hundred million GPUs out there now. Every cloud has it. It goes back to the A10, A100, H100, H200, the L series, the P series. There’s a whole bunch of them. They're in all kinds of sizes and shapes. If you're a robotics company, you want that
[Guest] CUDA 栈能直接跑在机器人本体里。我们真的是无处不在。装机量意味着，一旦你把软件或模型开发出来，它几乎到处都能派上用场。这一点价值高得惊人。最后，我们存在于每一家云里，这件事也让我们真正与众不同。如果你是一家 AI 公司或者开发者，你其实并不完全确定自己最终会和哪家云服务商合作，或者想把它跑在哪里。
CUDA stack to actually run in the robot itself. We're literally everywhere. The install base means that once you develop the software or the model, it's going to be useful everywhere. That is just incredibly valuable. Lastly, the fact that we're in every single cloud makes us genuinely unique. If you're an AI company or developer, you're not exactly sure which cloud service provider you're going to partner with or where you'd like to run it.
[Host] 我们哪儿都能跑，包括如果你愿意的话，也可以为你部署在本地机房。生态系统的丰富度、庞大的装机基础，再加上我们部署位置的灵活性，这些结合起来让 CUDA 变得无比有价值。这很有道理。我想我真正好奇的是，这些优势对你们的核心客户来说，是不是真的那么重要。
We run everywhere, including on-prem for you if you like. The combination of the richness of the ecosystem, the expansiveness of the install base, and the versatility of where we are makes CUDA invaluable. That makes a lot of sense. I guess the thing I'm curious about is whether those
[Host] 这些优势对你们的核心客户来说，是不是真的那么重要。确实有很多人会在意这些。但那些真正有能力自己搭软件栈的人，构成了你们大部分收入来源。尤其如果未来进入这样一个世界：AI 在那些有紧密可验证反馈回路、可以在其上做 RL 的任务上变得特别强……那问题就变成了，你要怎么写一个做 attention 或者
advantages matter a lot to your main customers. There's many people for whom they might matter. The kind of person who can actually build their own software stack makes up most of your revenue. Especially if you go to a world where AI is getting especially good at the things which have tight verification loops where you can RL on them…. This question of how do you write a kernel that does attention or
[Host] MLP 的 kernel，才能在大规模扩展场景下做到最高效率？这其实是一个非常容易验证的反馈回路。那些 hyperscaler 能不能自己给自己写这些定制 kernel？Nvidia 现在依然有很强的性价比，所以他们可能还是更愿意用 Nvidia。但接下来的问题是，这会不会最终只是变成一个拼参数的问题——谁能在同样的钱下提供最好的规格、最高的 flops 和内存带宽。而历史上，Nvidia 一直都是，而且现在也仍然是，
MLP the most efficiently across a scale up? It's a very verifiable sort of feedback loop. Can all the hyperscalers write these custom kernels for themselves? Nvidia still has great price performance, so they might still prefer to use Nvidia. But then the question is, does it just become a question of who is offering the best specs, the best flops and memory bandwidth for a given dollar. Whereas historically Nvidia has just had, and still has,
[Host] 整个 AI 领域里无论硬件还是软件利润率最高的公司，能到 70% 以上，就是因为 CUDA 这条护城河。问题在于，如果对你们大多数客户来说，他们其实负担得起自己去做这些，而不是依赖 CUDA 护城河，那你们还能维持这样的利润率吗？我们派到这些 AI 实验室去的工程师数量多得惊人，和他们一起工作，帮他们优化整套软件栈。
the best margins in all of AI across hardware and software, +70%, because of this CUDA moat. And the question is, can you sustain those margins if for most of your customers, they can actually afford to build, instead of the CUDA moat? The number of engineers we have assigned to these AI labs is insane, working with them, optimizing their stack.
[Guest] 原因就在于，没有人比我们更懂自己的架构。这些架构不像 CPU 那么通用。CPU 有点像 Cadillac，开起来很舒服，很适合巡航，不会特别快。基本上谁都能把它开得不错，还有巡航控制之类的功能，一切都很轻松。
The reason for that is because nobody knows our architecture better than we do. These architectures are not as general purpose as a CPU. A CPU is kind of like a Cadillac. It's a nice cruiser. It never goes too fast. Everybody drives it pretty well. It's got cruise control, and everything's easy.
[Guest] 但从很多方面来说，Nvidia 的 GPU、加速器，更像是 F1 赛车。我可以想象，大家都能把它开到时速一百英里，但真要把它推到极限，就需要相当高的专业能力。我们也大量使用 AI 来生成我们现在这些 kernel。我很确定，在相当长一段时间里，我们仍然是不可或缺的。
But in a lot of ways, Nvidia's GPUs, accelerators, are like F1 racers. I could imagine everybody's able to drive it at a hundred miles an hour, but it takes quite a bit of expertise to be able to push it to the limit. We use a ton of AI to create the kernels that we have. I'm pretty sure we're
[Guest] 我们的专业能力，往往能帮助这些 AI 实验室合作伙伴轻松把他们的软件栈性能再提升 2 倍。很多时候这并不稀奇：等我们把他们的软件栈或者某个特定 kernel 优化完，他们的模型速度会提升 3 倍、2 倍，或者 50%。
going to still be needed for quite some time. Our expertise helps our AI lab partners to get another 2x out of their stack easily oftentimes. It's not unusual that by the time we're done optimizing their stack or optimizing a particular kernel, their model sped up by 3x, 2x, 50%.
[Guest] 这可是个非常巨大的数字，尤其是考虑到他们现有的大规模装机群，也就是他们手上的那些 Hopper 和 Blackwell。你把性能提升一倍，就等于收入翻倍。这会直接转化成收入。Nvidia 的计算软件栈在全球范围内拥有最佳的 TCO 性能表现，毫无争议。到今天为止，还没有人能向我证明，世界上有任何一个平台能提供更好的
That's a huge number, especially when you're talking about the install base of the fleet that they have, of all the Hoppers and Blackwells that they have. When you increase it by a factor of two, that doubles the revenues. That directly translates to revenues. Nvidia's computing stack is the best performance per TCO in the world, bar none. Nobody can demonstrate to me that any single platform in the world today has a better
[Guest] 性能-TCO 比。不是某一家公司。事实上，现在外面已经有公开基准了。Dylan 的 InferenceMAX 就摆在那里，谁都可以用，但没有一家……TPU 不来，Trainium 也不来。我鼓励他们用 InferenceMAX，展示一下他们惊人的推理成本。
performance-TCO ratio. Not one company. In fact, the benchmarks that are out there. Dylan's InferenceMAX is sitting out there for everybody to use, and not one… TPU won't come, Trainium won't come. I encourage them to use InferenceMAX and demonstrate their incredible inference
[Guest] 这真的很难。没人愿意站出来。MLPerf 也是一样。我很欢迎 Trainium 来展示一下他们老挂在嘴边的 40%。我也很想听听他们证明 TPU 的成本优势。在我看来这根本说不通，完全说不通。从最基本的原理上看，就说不通。
cost. It's really hard. Nobody wants to show up. MLPerf. I would welcome Trainium to demonstrate their 40% that they claim all the time. I would love to hear them demonstrate the cost advantage of TPUs. It makes no sense in my mind. It makes absolutely zero sense. On first principles, it makes no sense.
[Guest] 所以我觉得我们之所以这么成功，原因很简单，就是因为我们的 TCO 非常出色。第二，你说我们 60% 的客户来自前五大，但其中大部分业务其实都是外部的。比如说，AWS 上大多数 Nvidia 的使用都是给外部客户的，不是内部自用。我们在 Azure 的客户也大多如此，当然，我们所有客户都是外部客户。
So I think the reason why we're so successful is simply because our TCO is so great. Secondly, you say 60% of our customers are the top five, but most of that business is external. For example, most of Nvidia in AWS is for external customers, not internal use. Most of our customers at Azure, obviously all of our customers are external.
[Guest] 我们在 OCI 的所有客户也都是外部客户，不是内部使用。他们偏向我们的原因，是因为我们的覆盖范围太广了。我们能把全球最优质的客户都带给他们。他们全都建立在 Nvidia 之上。而这些公司之所以都建立在 Nvidia 之上，是因为我们的覆盖能力和通用性都非常强。所以我认为这个飞轮真正的核心是装机基础，
All of our customers at OCI are external, not internal use. The reason why they favor us is because our reach is so great. We can bring them all of the great customers in the world. They're all built on Nvidia. And the reason why all these companies are built on Nvidia is because our reach and our versatility is so great. So I think the flywheel is really install base,
[Guest] 是我们架构的可编程性，是我们生态系统的丰富度，以及现在全球有这么多 AI 公司。现在已经有成千上万家了。如果你是这些 AI 初创公司中的一家，你会选什么架构？你会选供应最充足的架构。我们是全球供应最充足的。你会选装机量最大的那个。我们的装机基础最大。你还会选一个拥有
the programmability of our architecture, the richness of our ecosystem, and the fact that there's so many AI companies in the world. There's tens of thousands of them now. If you were one of those AI startups, what architecture would you choose? You would choose an architecture that's most abundant. We're the most abundant in the world. You’d choose the one that has the largest installed base. We're the largest install base. And you’d choose the one that has a
[Guest] 丰富生态的架构。所以这就是飞轮。这也是为什么，综合来看：第一，我们的每美元性能非常强，所以他们的 token 成本最低。第二，我们的每瓦性能是全球最高的。所以如果这些公司、如果我们的合作伙伴建一个 1 吉瓦的数据中心，
rich ecosystem. So that's the flywheel. That's the reason why, between the combination of: one, our perf per dollar is so great that they have the lowest cost tokens. Second, our perf per watt is the highest in the world. So if one of these companies, if our partners, built a one gigawatt data center,
[Guest] 那这个 1 吉瓦的数据中心就最好能带来最大的营收和最多的 token，而这两者是直接对应的。你当然希望它尽可能多地产生 token，把这个数据中心的营收最大化。我们是全球每瓦 token 产出最高的架构。最后，如果你的目标是把基础设施租出去，我们拥有全球最多的客户。所以这就是为什么这个飞轮能运转。
that one gigawatt data center better deliver the maximum amount of revenues and number of tokens, which directly translates to revenues. You want it to generate as many tokens as possible, maximize the revenues for that data center. We are the highest tokens per watt architecture in the world. Lastly, if your goal is to rent the infrastructure, we have the most customers in the world. So that's the reason why the flywheel works.
[Host] 有意思。我想问题归根结底在于，这里的市场结构到底是什么样的？因为即便还有别的公司……本来也可能存在这样一种世界：有成千上万家 AI 公司，它们大致平均地占有算力份额。但即使是在这五大 hyperscaler 之中，真正使用 Amazon 上这些算力的人，其实是 Anthropic、OpenAI，以及这些大型基础模型实验室，它们自己也负担得起，而且也有能力拥有
Interesting. I guess the question comes down to, what is the actual market structure here? Because even if there's other companies… There could have been a world where there's tens of thousands of AI companies that have roughly equal share of compute. But even through these five hyperscalers, really the people on Amazon using the compute are Anthropic, OpenAI, and these big foundation labs who can themselves afford and have
[Host] 让不同加速器协同工作的能力。不，我觉得你的前提就错了。也许吧。但我换个方式问你一个稍微不同的问题。回头你再来纠正我的前提。好吧，那我就换个问题问。不过你还是得回来帮我把这个问题掰正，因为这对 AI 太重要了。对未来的科学太重要了。对整个行业的未来也太重要了。
the ability to make different accelerators work. No, I think your premise is wrong. Maybe. But let me ask you a slightly different question. Come back and make me correct your premise. Okay. Let me just ask you a different question. But still make sure to make me come back and fix because it's just too important to AI. It's too important to the future of science. It's too important to the future of
[Host] 那个前提……你看——先让我把问题问完，然后我们可以一起聊这个。好。如果关于价格、性能、单位功耗性能等等这些判断都成立，那你为什么觉得会出现这种情况：比如 Anthropic，几天前刚宣布和 Broadcom、Google 达成一个数吉瓦级别的合作，用 TPU 承担他们大部分算力。显然对 Google 来说，
the industry. That premise… Look — Let me just finish the question and then we can address it together. Yeah. If all these things are true about price, performance, and performance per watt, et cetera, are true, why do you think it is the case that, say, Anthropic for example, just announced a couple days ago they have a multi-gigawatt deal with Broadcom and Google for TPUs and majority of their compute? Obviously for Google,
[Guest] TPU 本来就是他们大部分算力来源。所以如果我看这些大型 AI 公司，会感觉他们很多算力……曾经有那么一个阶段，几乎全是 Nvidia，现在已经不是了。所以我很好奇，如果这些东西在纸面上都成立，为什么他们还会选择别的加速器？Anthropic 是个特殊案例，不是趋势。没有 Anthropic，TPU 还会有什么增长吗？100% 都是 Anthropic。没有
TPU is a majority of compute. So if I look at these big AI companies, it seems like a lot of their compute… There was some point where it's all Nvidia and now it's not. So I'm curious how to square, if these things are true on paper, why are they going with other accelerators? Anthropic is a unique instance, not a trend. Without Anthropic, why would there be any TPU growth at all? It's 100% Anthropic. Without
[Host] Anthropic，Trainium 还会有什么增长吗？100% 都是 Anthropic。我觉得这一点其实大家都很清楚，也都理解。并不是说 ASIC 的机会遍地都是。Anthropic 只有一个。但 OpenAI 和 AMD 的合作呢……他们还在做自己的 Titan 加速器。对，但我觉得我们都承认，他们绝大多数还是用 Nvidia。我们之后还是会一起做很多工作。
Anthropic, why would there be Trainium growth at all? It's 100% Anthropic. I think that's fairly well known and well understood. It's not that there's an abundance of ASIC opportunities. There's only one Anthropic. But OpenAI's deals with AMD… They're building their own Titan accelerator. Yeah, but I think we could all acknowledge they're vastly Nvidia. We're going to still do a lot of work together.
[Guest] 别人用别的东西、去做各种尝试，我并不介意。如果他们不去试这些别的方案，他们怎么知道我们的东西有多好？有时候你就是得被提醒一下。我们必须持续不断地去赢得我们现在所处的位置。外面总会有很多宏大的说法。你看看有多少 ASIC 项目最后都被砍掉了。不是说你要做一个 ASIC……你就真的能做出比 Nvidia 更好的东西。
I'm not offended by other people using something else and trying things. If they don't try these other things, how would they know how good ours is? Sometimes you've got to be reminded of it. We have to continuously earn the position that we're in. There are always big claims. Look at the number of ASICs that have been canceled. Just because you're going to build an ASIC… You still have to build something better than Nvidia.
[Host] 要做出比 Nvidia 更好的东西，没那么容易。说实话，这事本身就不太合理。Nvidia 肯定是漏掉了什么，真的。凭我们的规模和迭代速度，我们是全世界唯一一家每年都能持续推出产品的公司。每年都是大跨越。我猜他们的逻辑是：“嘿，不一定非得更好。只要别比你们差超过 70% 就行。”因为他们觉得你们拿了 70% 的利润率。不，别忘了，就算是 ASIC，利润率其实也相当高。
It's not that easy building something better than Nvidia. It's not sensible, actually. Nvidia's got to be missing something, seriously. Because of our scale, our velocity, we're the only company in the world that's cranking it out every single year. Big leaps, every single year. I guess their logic is, "Hey, it doesn't need to be better. It just needs to be not more than 70% worse," because they're paying you 70% margins. No, don't forget, even in ASICs margins are really quite high.
[Guest] 假设 Nvidia 的利润率是 70%，但 ASIC 的利润率是 65%。那你到底省下了什么？哦，你是说从 Broadcom 这类公司那里买吗？对，当然。你总得付钱给某个人。据我所知，ASIC 的利润率高得惊人。他们自己也这么认为。他们对自己惊人的 ASIC 利润率还挺自豪的。所以，你刚才问的是为什么。
Nvidia's margin is 70%, let's say. But ASIC margins are 65%. What are you really saving? Oh, you mean from Broadcom or something like that? Yeah, sure. You've got to pay somebody. I think the ASIC margins are incredibly good, from what I can tell. They believe it too. They're quite proud of their incredible ASIC margins. So, you asked the question why.
[Guest] 很久以前，我们就是没有这个能力去做这件事。那时候，我还没有真正深刻意识到，要建立一个像 OpenAI、Anthropic 这样的基础 AI 实验室有多难，以及他们需要巨大的
A long time ago, we just didn't have the ability to do it. At the time, I didn't deeply internalize how difficult it would be to build a foundation AI lab like OpenAI and Anthropic, and the fact that they needed huge
[Guest] 来自供应商自身的投资。我们当时确实没有能力向 Anthropic 投入数十亿美元，好让他们使用我们的算力。但 Google 和 AWS 可以。他们一开始就投了巨额资金，作为交换，Anthropic 使用他们的算力。我们当时就是做不到这一点。要说我的失误，那就是——
investments from the supplier themselves. We just weren't in a position to make the multi-billion dollar investment into Anthropic so that they could use our compute. But Google and AWS were. They put in huge investments in the beginning so that Anthropic, in return, used their compute. We just weren't in a position to do that at the time. I would say my mistake is
[Guest] 我当时没有真正深刻意识到，他们其实根本没有别的选择。VC 不可能往一家 AI 实验室里投 50 到 100 亿美元，只是希望它最后能成长成 Anthropic。所以这是我的判断失误。但即便我当时明白这一点，我觉得我们那时也还是做不到。不过同样的错误，我不会再犯第二次。
I didn't deeply internalize that they really had no other options, that a VC would never put in $5-10 billion of investment into an AI lab with the hopes of it turning out to be Anthropic. So that was my miss. But even if I understood it, I don't think we would've been in a position to do that at the time. But I'm not going to make that same mistake again.
[Guest] 我很高兴投资 OpenAI，也很高兴帮助他们扩张规模，而且我相信这么做至关重要。后来等我有能力了，Anthropic 找到我们时，我也很高兴成为投资方，很高兴帮助他们扩张。只是我们当时确实做不到。如果一切能重来——而且 Nvidia 那时候就能像现在这么大——
I'm delighted to invest in OpenAI, and I'm delighted to help them scale, and I believe it's essential to do so. And then, when I was able to, when Anthropic came to us, I'm delighted to be an investor, delighted to help them scale. We just weren't, at the time, able to do it. If I could rewind everything—and Nvidia could
[Host] 我会非常乐意这么做。这其实挺有意思的。很多年来，Nvidia 一直是 AI 领域里赚钱的公司，而且赚了很多钱。现在你们开始把这些钱投出去了。据报道，你们在 OpenAI 上最多投了 300 亿美元，在 Anthropic 上投了 100 亿美元。但现在他们的估值已经涨了，
have been as big back then as we are now—I would've been more than happy to do it. This is actually quite interesting. For many years Nvidia has been the company in AI making money, making lots of money. Now you're investing it. It's been reported that you've done up to $30 billion in OpenAI and $10 billion in Anthropic. But now their valuations have increased,
[Host] 而且我相信还会继续涨。所以如果这些年里你们一直在给他们提供算力，也看到了趋势，而几年前——有些甚至是一年前——他们的估值还只有现在的大概十分之一，同时你们手上又有这么多现金，那其实完全存在这样一种可能：要么 Nvidia 自己变成一家基础模型实验室，靠巨额投资把这件事做成；要么就是把你们现在这些交易，在当时更早、估值更低的时候就做了。
and I'm sure they'll continue to increase. So if over these many years you were giving them the compute, you saw where it was headed, and they were worth like one tenth what they're worth now a couple years ago—or even a year ago in some cases and you had all this cash — there's a world where either Nvidia themselves becomes a foundation lab, does a huge investment to make that possible, or has made the deals you've made now at current valuations much earlier on.
[Host] 而且你们当时也有这个现金。所以我其实很好奇，为什么不更早做？我们是在一有能力的时候就做了。我们是在一有能力的时候就做了，如果我能更早做，我一定会更早做。Anthropic 当时需要我们这么做的时候，我们确实还没有这个能力。这也不符合我们当时的思维方式。怎么说？是现金的问题吗？对，主要是投资规模的问题。我们当时从来没有做过公司外部投资，
And you had the cash to do it. So I am curious, actually, why not have done it earlier? We did it as soon as we could have. We did it as soon as we could have, and if I could have, I would've done it even earlier. At the time that Anthropic needed us to do it, we just weren't in a position to do it. It wasn't in our sensibility to do so. How so? Was it like a cash thing? Yeah, the level of investment. We had never invested outside the company
[Guest] 而且也从没投过这么大的金额。我们当时没意识到这是必须的。我一直以为，他们完全可以像其他公司一样，去找 VC 融资啊，拜托。但他们想做的事情，根本不是靠 VC 能完成的。OpenAI 想做的事，也不是靠 VC 能完成的。现在我明白了。当时我并不知道。
at the time, and not that much. We didn't realize we needed to. I always thought that they could just go raise from VCs, for God's sakes, like all companies do. But what they were trying to do couldn't have been done through VCs. What OpenAI wanted to do couldn't have been done through VCs. I recognize that now. I didn't know
[Guest] 但这正是他们厉害的地方，这就是他们聪明之处。他们当时就意识到，自己必须这么做。我也很高兴他们这么做了。虽然我们让 Anthropic 不得不去找别人，但我还是很高兴这件事发生了。Anthropic 的存在对这个世界是好事，我为此感到高兴。我想你们现在还是赚了很多很多钱，而且你们的赚钱方式也很——
it then. But that's their genius. That's why they're smart. They realized then that they had to do something like that. And I'm delighted that they did. Even though we caused Anthropic to have to go to somebody else, I'm still happy that it happened. Anthropic's existence is great for the world. I'm delighted for it. I guess you still are making a ton of money, and you're making way
[Host] 一季接一季赚更多钱。就算这样，有遗憾也还是正常的。所以问题还是会出现。好，现在你们已经走到这一步了，而且还在不断赚这么多钱，Nvidia 应该拿这些钱做什么？有一种答案是，现在已经冒出来了一个完整的中间商生态，专门帮这些实验室把 CapEx 转成 OpEx，这样他们就能租算力。因为这些芯片真的很贵，但由于 AI 模型越来越强，它们在整个生命周期里也能赚很多钱。
more money quarter after quarter. It's still okay to have regrets. So the question still arises. Okay, now that we're here and you have all this money that you keep making, what should Nvidia be doing with it? There's one answer which is that there's this whole middleman ecosystem that has popped up for converting CapEx into OpEx for these labs so that they can rent compute. Because the chips are really expensive, they make a lot of money over their lifetime because the AI models are getting better.
[Host] 所以它们创造的价值，也就是产出的 tokens，在不断上升，但前期部署成本很高。Nvidia 有钱来做这些 CapEx。事实上，据报道，你们正在为 CoreWeave 提供最高 63 亿美元的兜底支持，还投资了 20 亿美元。那 Nvidia 为什么不自己做云？为什么不自己变成 hyperscaler，把这些算力租出去？你们手上明明有这么多现金可以做。这其实涉及公司的一个理念，而且我觉得这很明智。
So the value that they generate, their tokens, is increasing, but they're expensive to set up. Nvidia has the money to do the CapEx. In fact, it's been reported, you are backstopping CoreWeave up to $6.3 billion and have invested $2 billion. Why doesn't Nvidia become a cloud themselves? Why doesn't it become a hyperscaler themselves and rent this compute out? You have all this cash to do it. This is a philosophy of the company, and I think it's wise.
[Guest] 我们应该做“尽可能有必要的事，但尽可能少做”。这句话的意思是，我们在构建计算平台这件事上，如果我们不做，我真心相信这件事就不会有人做成。如果我们不去承担我们承担的这些风险——如果我们没有按现在这种方式做出 NVLink，如果我们没有把整套技术栈搭起来，如果我们没有像现在这样建立起整个生态，如果我们没有在 20 年里始终投入到
We should do as much as needed, as little as possible. What that means is, the work that we do with building our computing platform, if we don't do it, I genuinely believe it doesn't get done. If we didn't take the risk that we take—if we didn't build NVLink the way we built it, if we didn't build the whole stack, if we didn't create the ecosystem the way we did, if we didn't dedicate ourselves to 20 years of
[Guest] CUDA 上，而且其中大部分时间还在亏钱——如果我们不做，就不会有别人来做。如果我们没有做出所有这些 CUDA-X 库，让它们都面向特定领域……十五年前，我们就开始推进领域专用库，因为我们意识到，如果我们不去做这些领域专用库，不管是光线追踪、图像生成，还是 AI 的早期工作、这些模型，如果我们不去做它们，还有数据处理、结构化数据
CUDA while losing money most of that time—if we didn't do it, nobody else would have done it. If we didn't create all the CUDA-X libraries so that they're all domain-specific… A decade and a half ago, we pushed into domain-specific libraries because we realized that if we didn't create these domain-specific libraries, whether it's for ray tracing or image generation or even the early works of AI, these models, if we didn't create them, for data processing, structured data
[Guest] 处理，或者向量数据处理，如果我们不做，就没人会做。我对此完全确定。我们还做了一个用于计算光刻的库，叫 cuLitho。如果不是我们做，也不会有人做。所以，如果没有我们做的这些事，加速计算不会像今天这样发展。所以这些事我们就应该做。我们应该把公司、把我们全部的力量，毫无保留地投入到这件事上。
processing, or vector data processing, if we didn't create them, nobody would. I am completely certain of that. We created a library for computational lithography called cuLitho. If we didn't create it, nobody would have. So accelerated computing wouldn't advance the way it has if we didn't do what we did. So we should do that. We should dedicate our company, all of our might, wholeheartedly to go do that.
[Guest] 但是，世界上已经有很多云厂商了。如果我不做，也会有人出来做。所以按照这个原则、这个理念——做尽可能有必要的事，但尽可能少做——尽可能少做，这个理念今天依然存在于我们公司里。我做的每一件事，都是用这个视角来判断的。拿云来说，如果我们当时不支持
However, the world has lots of clouds. If I didn't do it, somebody would show up. So following the recipe, the philosophy, of doing as much as needed but as little as possible—as little as possible—that philosophy exists in our company today. Everything I do, I do it with that lens. In the case of clouds, if we didn't support
[Guest] CoreWeave 的存在，这些 neocloud、这些 AI 云就不会存在。如果我们不帮助 CoreWeave 活下来，它们就不会存在。如果我们不支持 Nscale，他们也不会走到今天这个位置。如果我们不支持 Nebius，他们也不会成为今天的样子。现在他们都发展得非常好。这算是一种商业模式吗[听不清]？我们应该做尽可能有必要的事，尽可能少做。所以我们会投资我们的生态
CoreWeave to exist, these neoclouds, these AI clouds, wouldn't exist. If we didn't help CoreWeave exist, they would not exist. If we didn't support Nscale, they wouldn't be where they are today. If we didn't support Nebius, they wouldn't be what they are today. Now they're doing fantastically. Is that a business model [inaudible]? We should do as much as needed, as little as possible. So we invest in our ecosystem
[Guest] 因为我希望我们的生态能够繁荣。我希望这种架构，以及 AI，能够连接尽可能多的行业、尽可能多的国家，并让整个地球都能建立在 AI 之上，也建立在美国技术栈之上。这正是我们正在追求的愿景。现在，你刚才提到的一点是……
because I want our ecosystem to thrive. I want the architecture, and AI, to be able to connect with as many industries as possible, as many countries as possible, and make it possible for the planet to be built on AI and to be built on the American tech stack. That vision is exactly what we're pursuing. Now, one of the things that you mentioned…
[Guest] 有很多非常优秀、很了不起的 foundation model 公司，我们会尽量投资所有这些公司。这也是我们在做的另一件事。我们不选赢家。我们需要支持所有人。这也是我们做这件事的乐趣之一，而且这对我们的业务来说是必须的。但我们也会刻意避免去选赢家。所以当我投资其中一家时，我其实会把其他家也一起投。你为什么要刻意不去选赢家呢？
There are so many great, amazing foundation model companies, and we try to invest in all of them. This is another thing that we do. We don't pick winners. We need to support everyone. It's part of our joy of doing so. It's imperative to our business. But we also go out of our way not to pick winners. So when I invest in one of them, I invest in all of them. Why do you go out of your way not to pick winners?
[Guest] 因为第一，这不是我们的工作。第二，Nvidia 刚创立的时候，市面上有 60 家 3D 图形公司。最后活下来的只有我们这一家。如果你当时把那 60 家图形公司摆在一起，问自己哪一家能成，Nvidia 绝对会排在最不被看好的名单前列。这事发生在你出生之前很久了，但 Nvidia 当时的图形架构是彻头彻尾地错了。
Because it's not our job to, number one. Number two, when Nvidia first started, there were 60 3D graphics companies. We are the only one that survived. If you would have taken those 60 graphics companies and asked yourself which one was going to make it, Nvidia would be at the top of that list not to make it. This is long before you, but Nvidia's graphics architecture was precisely wrong.
[Guest] 不是有一点点错。我们做出来的是一个完全错位的架构，对开发者来说几乎不可能支持。它本来根本不可能成功。我们是基于很好的第一性原理去推导的，但最后却得出了错误的方案。所有人都会觉得我们没戏。而现在我们却走到了今天。
It's not a little bit wrong. We created an architecture that was precisely wrong, and it was an impossible thing for developers to support. It was never going to make it. We reasoned about it from good first principles, but we ended up with the wrong solution. Everybody would have counted us out. And here we
[Host] 所以我对此有足够的谦卑。别去选赢家。要么让他们各自靠自己发展，要么就把所有人都照顾到。有一点我没太明白，你刚才说，“我们并不是因为这些 neoclouds 是 neoclouds，想把它们扶起来，所以才优先照顾它们。”但你又列举了一堆 neoclouds，还说如果没有 NVIDIA，它们根本不会存在。这两点怎么能同时成立？
are. So I have enough humility to recognize that. Don't pick winners. Either let them all take care of themselves, or take care of all of them. One thing I didn't understand is you said, "Look, we're not prioritizing these neoclouds just because they are neoclouds and we want to prop them up." But you also listed a bunch of neoclouds and said they wouldn't exist if it wasn't for NVIDIA. How are those two things compatible?
[Guest] 首先，它们自己得想要存在，而且是它们主动来找我们帮忙。当它们想做这件事，也有商业计划、专业能力，以及那份热情时……当然，它们自己本身也必须具备一些能力。但如果说到最后，它们需要一些投资才能把事情启动起来，那我们会在那儿支持它们。不过，它们越早把自己的飞轮转起来越好……
First of all, they need to want to exist, and they come to ask us for help. When they want to exist and they have a business plan, expertise, and the passion for it… They obviously have to have some capabilities themselves. But if, at the end of the day, they need some investment in order to get it off the ground, we would be there for them. But the sooner they get their flywheel going...
[Guest] 你的问题其实是，“我们想不想做融资这门生意？”答案是不想。融资这件事有专门的人在做，我们更愿意和融资行业里的所有人合作，而不是自己变成资方。我们的目标是专注做好我们自己的事，让商业模式尽可能简单，并支持我们的生态系统。像 OpenAI 这样的公司，在 IPO 之前如果需要一笔 300 亿美元规模的投资，而我们又非常相信他们，我个人也非常相信他们会成为一家……嗯，他们今天已经是一家非凡的公司了。
Your question was, "Do we want to be in the financing business?" The answer is no. There are people in the financing business, and we'd rather work with all the people in the financing business than be a financier ourselves. Our goal is to focus on what we do, keep our business model as simple as possible, and support our ecosystem. When someone like OpenAI needs an investment of a $30 billion scale because it's still before
[Guest] 他们将会成为一家不可思议的公司。这个世界需要他们存在，这个世界也希望他们存在。我希望他们存在。他们现在正顺风顺水。那我们就支持他们，让他们扩大规模。
their IPO, and we deeply believe in them and I deeply believe that they're going to be an… Well, they're an extraordinary company already today. They’re going to be an incredible company. The world needs them to exist. The world wants them to exist. I want them to exist. They have the wind at their back. Let's support them and let them scale.
[Host] 这类投资我们会做，是因为他们需要我们这么做。但我们不是想尽可能多做，而是想尽可能少做。我花了太多时间在 Google Docs 和聊天机器人之间来回复制粘贴文本。所以我做了一个基本上可以说是“写作版 Cursor”的东西，它的运作方式就是我心目中 AI 协作研究助手该有的样子。我可以 @ 它，它也能通过行内评论线程和我对话，帮我挖得更深、一起头脑风暴。整个东西我都是周末用 Cursor 和他们新的 Composer 2 模型搭出来的。
Those investments we'll do because they need us to do it. But we're not trying to do as much as possible. We're trying to do as little as possible. I spend way too much time copy-pasting text back and forth from Google Docs to chatbots. And so I built what's basically a “Cursor for writing”, which operates the way I think an AI co-researcher should operate. I can tag it and it can talk with me through inline comment threads and help me dig deeper and brainstorm. I built this entire thing over the weekend with Cursor and their new Composer 2 model.
[Host] 很多 agentic coding 工具都会让我觉得，我根本不知道底层到底发生了什么。我只能放弃控制权，然后听天由命。但 Cursor 让我能一边保持对实现过程的掌控，一边尝试各种不同的想法。我的大部分头脑风暴都是在 agents 窗口里完成的，等基础文件搭起来之后，我就用 diff 窗口来跟踪改动。少数几次我需要手动快速微调的时候，就直接用编辑器。如果你也想亲自试试我这个 AI 协作研究员，我把 GitHub 仓库链接放在简介里了。要是你也一直有个想做的工具，那就现在把它做出来吧。去 cursor.com/dwarkesh 开始。
With a lot of agentic coding tools, I feel like I have no idea what's going on under the surface. I just have to relinquish control and hope for the best. But Cursor let me try a bunch of different ideas while staying on top of the implementation. I did most of my brainstorming in the agents window, and after I got some basic files in place, I used the diff window to track changes. The few times that I needed to make a quick tweak by hand, I just used the editor. If you want to try my AI co-researcher yourself I've linked the GitHub repo in the description. And if you have a tool that you've been wanting to build, you should make it happen. Go to cursor.com/dwarkesh to get started.
[Host] 这可能是个很明显的问题，但这么多年来我们一直都处在这样一种局面里：GPU 一直短缺，而且现在因为模型越来越强，这种短缺更严重了。我们现在就是缺 GPU。对。大家都知道，Nvidia 在分配这些稀缺额度时，不只是看谁出价最高，而是会想："我们得确保这些 neocloud 还能存在。给 CoreWeave 一些，再给一些给…"
This may be an obvious question, but we've lived many years in this situation where there's a shortage of GPUs, and it's grown now because models are getting better. We have a shortage of GPUs. Yes. Nvidia is known for divvying up the scarce allocation, not just based on high bidder, but rather on, "Hey, we want to make sure that these neoclouds exist. Let's give some to CoreWeave, let's give some to
[Guest] Crusoe，我们给 Lambda 也分一些。” 这对 Nvidia 为什么有好处？首先，你认同这种“把市场切碎”的说法吗？不，不认同。你的前提就错了。我们对这些事情一直都非常谨慎。我们非常重视这些事。首先，如果你不下 PO，那么所有的……
Crusoe, let's give some to Lambda." Why is it good for Nvidia? First of all, would you agree with this characterization of fracturing the market? No. No. Your premise is just wrong. We're sufficiently mindful about these things. We're very mindful about these things. First of all, if you don't place a PO, all the
[Guest] 光说是没用的。拿不到 PO，我们还能怎么办？所以第一件事就是，我们会和所有相关方一起非常努力地把预测做好，因为这些东西建起来要很长时间，数据中心建起来也要很长时间。我们就是通过预测来让需求和供给对齐，诸如此类。明白吗？
talking in the world won't make a difference. Until we get a PO, what are we going to do? So the first thing is, we work really hard with everybody to get a forecast done, because these things take a long time to build, and the data centers take a long time to build. We align ourselves with demand and supply and things like that through forecasting. Okay?
[Guest] 那是第一要务。第二，我们已经尽量和更多人一起做预测了，但说到底，你还是得下单。也许因为某些原因，你没有下单。那我能怎么办？到了一定时候，就只能先到先得了。但除此之外，如果你这边还没准备好，比如你的数据中心还没准备好，或者某些组件还没就绪。
That's job number one. Number two, we've tried to forecast with as many people as possible, but in the final analysis, you still have to place an order. Maybe, for whatever reason, you didn't place your order. What can I do? At some point, first in, first out. But beyond that, if you're not ready because your data center's not ready, or certain components aren't ready
[Guest] 为了让你能把一个数据中心搭起来，我们可能会决定先服务另一位客户。这其实只是为了把我们自己工厂的产能利用率最大化。我们可能会在这方面做一些调整。除此之外，优先级基本上是先到先得。你得先下 PO。如果你不下 PO……当然，这里面也有不少故事。
to enable you to stand up a data center, we might decide to serve another customer first. That's just maximizing the throughput of our own factory. We might do some adjustments there. Aside from that, the prioritization is first in, first out. You've got to place a PO. If you don't place a PO… Now, of course, there are stories about that.
[Guest] 比如说，这一切某种程度上都始于一篇文章，说 Larry 和 Elon 跟我一起吃晚饭时求我给他们 GPU。那根本没发生过。我们的确一起吃了晚饭，绝对一起吃了，而且那顿饭非常愉快。但他们从来没有在任何时候求过 GPU。他们只需要下单就行。一旦他们下了单，我们就会尽全力去
For example, all of this kind of started from an article about Larry and Elon having dinner with me where they begged for GPUs. That never happened. We absolutely had dinner. We absolutely had dinner, and it was a wonderful dinner. At no time did they beg for GPUs. They just had to place an order. Once they place an order, we do our best to
[Host] 把产能交付给他们。我们这事并不复杂。好。所以听起来像是有个排队机制，然后要看你的数据中心是否准备好了，以及你什么时候下采购订单，再在某个时间拿到货。但听起来还是不像价高者得。这样做有什么原因吗……？我们从来不这么做。好。我们从来不会。为什么不直接让出价最高的人拿走？因为那是很糟糕的商业做法。你定好价格，然后大家就……
get the capacity to them. We're not complicated. Okay. So it sounds like there's a queue, and then based on whether your data center is ready and when you place a purchase order, you get them at a certain time. But it still doesn't sound like the highest bidder just gets it. Is there a reason to do it…? We never do that. Okay. We never do. Why not just do high bidder? Because it's a bad business practice. You set your price and then people
[Guest] 决定买还是不买。我知道芯片行业里别的公司会在需求更高的时候调价，但我们不会。这从来都不是我们的做法。你可以信赖我们。我更愿意做一个可靠的、
decide to buy it or not. I understand that others in the chip industry change their prices when demand is higher, but we just don't. That's just never been a practice of ours. You can count on us. I prefer to be dependable,
[Guest] 成为这个行业基石的公司。你不需要反复猜测。如果我给你报了一个价格，那就是这个价格，就这么定了。就算需求暴涨，也还是这样。反过来说，这也是你为什么会和 TSMC 保持高效合作关系，对吧？是啊，Nvidia 跟他们合作，算一算，差不多快 30 年了。
to be the foundation of the industry. You don't need to second-guess. If I quoted you a price, we quoted you a price. That's it. If demand goes through the roof, so be it. On the other end, that's why you have a productive relationship with TSMC, right? Yeah, Nvidia's been in business with them for, I guess, coming up on 30 years.
[Guest] Nvidia 和 TSMC 之间并没有法律合同。这里面总会有一种大致的公平。有时候我占便宜，有时候我吃点亏。有时候我拿到更好的条件，有时候条件差一点。但总体来说，这段关系非常了不起。我可以完全信任他们，也可以完全依靠他们。说到 Nvidia，有一点你是可以确定的，那就是今年，
Nvidia and TSMC don't have a legal contract. There's always some rough justice. Sometimes I'm right, sometimes I'm wrong. Sometimes I got a better deal, sometimes I got a worse deal. But overall, the relationship is incredible. I can completely trust them. I can completely depend on them. One of the things you can count on with Nvidia is that this year,
[Guest] Vera Rubin 会非常惊艳。明年，Vera Rubin Ultra 会推出。后年，Feynman 会推出。再下一年，名字我还没公布。你每一年都可以指望我们。你得去全世界再找另一支 ASIC 团队——随便你挑哪支 ASIC 团队——看看有没有谁能让你说：“我敢把全部身家押上去，我敢把整个业务都押上去，因为你们一定会
Vera Rubin is going to be incredible. Next year, Vera Rubin Ultra will come. The year after that, Feynman will come. And the year after that, I haven't introduced the name yet. Every single year you can count on us. You're going to have to go find another ASIC team in the world—pick your ASIC team—where you can say, "I can bet the farm, I can bet my entire business that you will be
[Guest] 每一年都在这里支持我。我的 token 成本每年都会下降一个数量级。我可以像相信时钟一样相信这件事。”我刚才说了 TSMC。历史上没有任何别的 foundry 能让你这么说。今天你可以对 Nvidia 这么说。你每一年都可以指望我们。如果你想买价值 10 亿美元的
here for me every single year. Your token cost will decrease by an order of magnitude every single year. I can count on it like I can count on the clock." I just said something about TSMC. For no other foundry in history can you possibly say that. You can say that about Nvidia today. You can count on us every single year. If you would like to buy a billion dollars
[Guest] AI factory 算力，没问题。如果你想买 1 亿美元的，没问题。想买 1000 万美元的，或者就买一个机架，也没问题。或者只买一张显卡，也行，没问题。如果你想下一个 1000 亿美元的 AI factory 订单，也没问题。今天全世界只有我们这一家公司能让你这么说。对 TSMC 我也可以这么说。我要买一个，还是买 10 亿个，都没问题。
worth of AI factory compute, no problem. If you'd like to buy a hundred million dollars, no problem. You'd like to buy $10 million, or just one rack, not a problem. Or just one graphics card, okay, no problem. If you would like to place an order for a $100 billion of AI factory, no problem. We're the only company in the world where you can say that today. I can say that about TSMC as well. I want to buy one, buy 1 billion, no problem.
[Guest] 我们只需要走完规划流程，以及成熟的人都会做的那些事情。所以我认为，Nvidia 能成为全球 AI 产业的基石，这个位置是我们花了几十年才走到的。巨大的投入，
We just have to go through the process of planning for it, and all the things that mature people do. So I think this ability for Nvidia to be the foundation of the world's AI industry, this is a position that has taken us a couple of decades to arrive at. Enormous commitment,
[Host] 巨大的专注。我们公司的稳定性、我们公司的一贯性，真的非常重要。好，我想问问中国。我其实也不确定自己对“该不该把芯片卖给中国”这件事到底怎么想，但我喜欢在节目里跟嘉宾唱反调。所以 Dario 来的时候，他支持出口管制，我就问他，为什么 America 和 China 不能都拥有一个由天才组成的数据中心国家？但既然你站在另一边，那我就反过来问你。
enormous dedication. The stability of our company, the consistency of our company, is really important. Okay. I want to ask about China. I actually don't know what I think about whether it's good to sell chips to China or not, but I like to play devil's advocate against my guests. So when Dario was on, who supports export controls, I asked him, why can't America and China both have a country of geniuses in the datacenter? But since you're on the opposite side, I'll ask you in the opposite way.
[Host] 有一种理解方式是，Anthropic 其实几天前刚宣布了 Mythos Preview。这个叫 Mythos 的模型，他们甚至都不打算公开发布，因为他们说它具备很强的网络攻击能力，在确认这些零日漏洞都被修补之前，他们觉得世界还没准备好。但他们说，这个模型在所有主流操作系统、所有浏览器里发现了成千上万个高危漏洞。它甚至还在 OpenBSD 里找到了一个漏洞，而这个操作系统本来就是专门为了避免出现零日漏洞而设计的。它找到的那个漏洞已经存在 27 年了。
One way to think about it is, Anthropic actually announced a couple days ago Mythos Preview. This model Mythos, they're not even releasing publicly because they say it has such cyber-offensive capabilities that we don't think the world is ready until we make sure these zero-days are patched up. But they say it found thousands of high-severity vulnerabilities across every major operating system, every browser. It found one in OpenBSD, which is this operating system that's been specifically designed to not have zero days. It found one that's existed for 27 years.
[Host] 所以，如果中国公司、中国实验室以及中国政府能拿到 AI 芯片，去训练一个像 Claude Mythos 这样具备网络攻击能力的模型，再用更多算力跑出数百万个实例，那问题就是：这会不会对美国公司、对美国国家安全构成威胁？首先，Mythos 的训练其实用的是相当
So if Chinese companies and Chinese labs and the Chinese government had access to the AI chips to train a model like Claude Mythos with these cyber-offensive capabilities and run millions of instances of it with more compute, the question is, is that a threat to American companies, to American national security? First of all, Mythos was trained on fairly
[Guest] 普通的能力规模，而且量也相当普通。只是出自一家非常了不起的公司。它训练时所用的算力规模和计算类型，在中国都很容易获得。所以你首先得意识到，中国是有芯片的。他们生产了全球 60% 的主流芯片，甚至可能更多。
mundane capacity, and a fairly mundane amount of it. By an extraordinary company. The amount of capacity and the type of compute it was trained on is abundantly available in China. So you just have to first realize that chips exist in China. They manufacture 60% of the world's mainstream chips, maybe more.
[Guest] 这对他们来说是个非常庞大的产业。他们拥有世界上一些最顶尖的计算机科学家。你也知道，这些 AI 实验室里的很多 AI 研究人员都是中国人。他们拥有全球 50% 的 AI 研究人员。所以问题是，考虑到他们已经拥有的这些资源——他们有充足的能源，也有大量芯片，还拥有大多数 AI 研究人员——如果你真的担心他们，那怎样才能打造一个更安全的世界？
It's a very large industry for them. They have some of the world's greatest computer scientists. As you know, most of the AI researchers in all of these AI labs are Chinese. They have 50% of the world's AI researchers. So the question is, considering all the assets they already have—they have an abundance of
[Guest] 把他们当成受害对象，对他们进行打压，把他们变成敌人，恐怕不是最好的答案。他们是竞争对手。我们当然希望美国赢。但我认为，开展对话、开展科研对话，可能才是最安全的做法。
energy, they have plenty of chips, they've got most of the AI researchers—if you're worried about them, what is the best way to create a safe world? Victimizing them, turning them into an enemy, likely isn't the best answer. They are an adversary. We want the United States to win.
[Guest] 而这一点恰恰是当前严重缺失的，因为我们现在把中国视为对手。让我们的 AI 研究人员和他们的 AI 研究人员真正交流起来，这一点至关重要。我们也必须努力就哪些事情不该用 AI 去做达成共识。
But I think having a dialogue and having research dialogue is probably the safest thing to do. This is an area that is glaringly missing because of our current attitude about China as an adversary. It is essential that our AI researchers and their AI researchers are actually talking. It is essential that we try to both
[Guest] 说到在软件里找 bug，这当然本来就是 AI 应该做的事。它会不会在大量软件里发现 bug？当然会。有非常非常多的 bug。AI 软件本身里也有很多 bug。这就是 AI 应该做的事，而且我很高兴 AI 已经发展到了这样一个水平，
agree on what not to use the AI for. With respect to finding bugs in software, of course, that's what AI is supposed to do. Is it going to find bugs in a lot of software? Of course. There are lots and lots of bugs. There are lots of bugs in the AI software. That's what AI is supposed to do, and I'm delighted that AI has reached a level where
[Guest] 它能帮助我们把生产力提高这么多。还有一点经常没有被充分强调，那就是围绕网络安全、AI 网络安全、AI 安全、AI 隐私和 AI 安全治理，已经形成了一个非常丰富的生态。这里面有一整个 AI 初创公司生态。
it could help us be so much more productive. One of the things that is underemphasized is the richness of the ecosystem around cybersecurity, AI cybersecurity and AI security and AI privacy and AI safety. There’s a whole ecosystem of AI startups
[Guest] 他们正在努力为我们创造这样一个未来：有一个非常强大的 AI agent，周围环绕着成千上万个 AI agents，负责保证它的安全、保证它的可靠。这个未来肯定会发生。你要说会有一个 AI agent 到处乱跑，却没有任何人盯着它，这种想法其实挺疯狂的。我们很清楚，这个生态系统必须繁荣发展。
that are trying to create this future for us, where you have one AI agent that's incredible, surrounded by thousands of AI agents, keeping it safe, keeping it secure. That future surely is going to happen. The idea that you're going to have an AI agent running around with nobody watching after it is kind of insane. We know very well that this ecosystem needs to thrive.
[Guest] 结果证明，这个生态系统需要开源，需要开放模型。还需要开放的技术栈，这样所有这些 AI 研究人员和优秀的计算机科学家，才能去构建同样强大、并且能够保障 AI 安全的系统。所以我们必须确保的一件事，就是让这个
It turns out this ecosystem needs open source. This ecosystem needs open models. They need open stacks so that all of these AI researchers and all these great computer scientists can go build AI systems that are as formidable and can keep AI safe. So one of the things that we need to make sure that we do is we keep the
[Guest] 开源生态保持活力。这一点不能被忽视。其中很大一部分正在来自中国。我们不应该去扼杀它。说到中国，当然，我们希望美国拥有尽可能多的算力。我们现在受限于能源，但已经有很多人在解决这个问题。
open source ecosystem vibrant. That can't be ignored. A lot of that is coming out of China. We ought to not suffocate that. With respect to China, of course we want the United States to have as much computing as possible. We're limited by energy, but we've got a lot of people working on that.
[Guest] 我们不能让能源成为这个国家的瓶颈。但我们同时也希望，确保全世界所有 AI 开发者都在美国的技术栈上开发，并且把 AI 的贡献和进步——尤其是在开源的情况下——带入美国的生态系统。要是人为造出两个
We've got to not make energy a bottleneck for our country. But what we also want is to make sure that all the AI developers in the world are developing on the American tech stack, and making the contributions, the advancements of AI—especially when it's open source—available to the American ecosystem. It would be extremely foolish to create two
[Host] 生态系统：一个是开源生态，但它只能跑在外国技术栈上；另一个是封闭生态，跑在美国技术栈上。我觉得这对美国来说会是一个非常糟糕的结果。这里面有很多点，我先简单梳理一下回应。我觉得大家担心的一个问题，回到黑客攻击里的 flop 差距，确实，他们有算力，但有一些估算认为，因为他们还停留在 7nm——由于芯片制造出口管制，他们拿不到 EUV——所以他们实际能产出的 flops 只有美国的十分之一。
ecosystems: the open source ecosystem, and it only runs on a foreign tech stack, and a closed ecosystem that runs on the American tech stack. I think that would be a horrible outcome for the United States. Since there are a lot of things, let me just triage the response. I think the concern, going back to the flop difference in the hacking, is yes, they have compute, but there's some estimates that because
[Host] 所以在这种情况下，他们最终能不能训练出像 Mythos 这样的模型？可以。但问题在于，因为我们的 flops 更多，美国实验室能更早达到这种能力水平。因为 Anthropic 先做到了，他们就可以说："好，我们先把它捂一个月，在这期间让所有这些美国公司先接入。
they're at 7nm—they don't have EUVs because of chip-making export controls—the amount of flops they're able to actually produce, they have one tenth the amount of flops that the US has. So with that, could they eventually train a model like Mythos? Yes. But the question is, because we have more flops, American labs are able to get to these levels of capabilities first. Because Anthropic got to it first, they say, "Okay, we're going to hold onto it for a month while all these American companies, we’ll give them access to it.
[Host] 他们会把自己的漏洞都补上，然后我们再发布。" 另外，就算他们训练出了这样的模型，能不能大规模部署又是另一回事……如果你有一个网络黑客，那他手里有一百万个这样的东西，和只有一千个，危险程度完全不是一个量级。所以推理算力真的非常重要。事实上，他们有那么多非常优秀的 AI 研究人员，这恰恰是最让人害怕的地方，因为真正让这些工程师和研究人员更高效的是什么？是算力。如果你去问美国任何一家 AI 实验室，他们都会说，限制他们的瓶颈就是算力。
They're going to patch up all their vulnerabilities, and now we release it." Furthermore, even if they train a model like this, the ability to deploy it at scale… If you had a cyber hacker, it's much more dangerous if they have a million of them versus a thousand of them. So that inference compute really matters a lot. In fact, the fact that they have so many AI researchers who are so good is the thing that makes it so scary, because what is it that makes those engineer researchers more productive? It’s compute. If you talk to any AI lab in America, they say the thing that's bottlenecking them is compute.
[Host] DeepSeek 的创始人，或者 Qwen 的管理层之类的人，都说过类似的话。他们说限制他们的瓶颈就是算力。那问题就来了：是不是更好让美国公司先到达 Mythos 级别的能力，因为他们有更多算力，这样我们就能在中国达到之前——因为他们算力更少——先让我们的社会做好准备？我们应该始终领先，也应该始终拥有更多。但要实现你刚才描述的那个结果，
There are quotes from the DeepSeek founder, or Qwen leadership or whatever. They say the thing they’re bottlenecked on is compute. So then the question is, isn't it better that we get American companies, because they have more compute, to get to the Mythos-level capabilities first, prepare our society for it, before China can get to it because, they have less compute? We should always be first and we should always have more. But in order for that outcome you described
[Guest] 如果这事真像你说的那样，那就得推到极端：他们必须一点算力都没有。可只要他们有算力，问题就变成他们到底需要多少。中国现有的算力量级非常惊人。你说的是全球第二大计算市场。如果他们想把算力整合起来，他们手上有的是算力可整合。
to be true, you have to take it to the extremes. They have to have no compute. If they have some compute, the question is how much is needed? The amount of compute they have in China is enormous. You're talking about the country that is the second largest computing market in the world. If they want to aggregate their compute, they've got plenty of compute to aggregate.
[Host] 但这是真的吗？大家会做各种估算，然后说“SMIC 在制程节点上其实是落后的。”我正要说这个。好。可他们拥有的能源规模也非常惊人，不是吗？AI 本来就是个并行计算问题，对吧？那他们为什么不能直接把芯片堆到 4 倍、10 倍那么多，反正能源几乎不要钱？他们能源太多了。他们有些 datacenter 是完全空着的，但电力都已经配齐了。你知道他们有鬼城，他们也有“鬼 datacenter”。
But is that true? People do these estimates and they're like, "SMIC is actually behind on the process nodes." I'm about to tell you. Okay. The amount of energy they have is incredible. Isn't that right? AI is a parallel computing problem, isn't it? Why can't they just put 4x, 10x, as many chips together because energy's free? They have so much energy. They have datacenters that are sitting completely empty, fully powered. You know they have ghost cities, they have ghost datacenters too.
[Guest] 他们的基础设施容量非常大。如果他们愿意，哪怕只是 7nm，也可以把更多芯片并起来用。他们造芯片的产能是全球最大的之一。半导体行业都知道，他们在主流芯片上几乎是垄断地位。他们是产能过剩，产能多到用不完。所以说中国搞不出 AI 芯片，这完全是无稽之谈。当然了，如果你要问我，
They have so much infrastructure capacity. If they wanted to, they just gang up more chips, even if they're 7nm. Their capacity of building chips is one of the largest in the world. The semiconductor industry knows that they monopolize mainstream chips. They have over-capacity, they have too much capacity. So the idea that China won't be able to have AI chips is completely nonsense. Now, of course, if you ask me,
[Guest] 如果全世界其他地方都完全没有算力，美国会不会领先得更多？会。但那根本不是现实结果，也不是一个真实会发生的情景。他们本来就已经有大量算力了。你担心的那个门槛，他们其实早就达到了，而且已经超过了。所以我觉得你可能误解了一点：AI 像一个五层蛋糕，最底层其实是能源。当你拥有充足的能源时，
would the United States be further ahead if the entire world had no compute at all? But that's just not an outcome. That's not a scenario that's true. They have plenty of compute already. The amount of threshold they need for the concern you're worried about, they've already reached that threshold and beyond. So I think you misunderstand that AI is a five-layer cake, and at the lowest layer is energy. When you have an abundance of energy,
[Guest] 它可以弥补芯片上的不足。反过来，如果你有大量芯片，也可以弥补能源上的不足。比如说，美国现在缺的是能源，这也是为什么 Nvidia 必须不断推进架构演进，做这种极致的协同设计。因为我们能出货的芯片数量有限——芯片就这么多，再加上能源又很紧张——所以我们每瓦吞吐量才会做到高得离谱。
it makes up for chips. If you have an abundance of chips, it makes up for energy. For example, the United States is scarce on energy, which is the reason why Nvidia has to keep advancing our architecture and do this extreme co-design so that with the few chips that we ship—with the few chips, because the amount of energy is so limited—our throughput per watt is off the charts.
[Guest] 但如果你的电力是完全充裕的，几乎等于免费，那你还在乎什么每瓦性能呢？你本来就够用。你甚至可以用老芯片来做。所以 7nm 芯片本质上已经接近 Hopper 这一代了。说到 Hopper 的能力……我得告诉你，现在的模型训练，很大一部分本来就是在 Hopper、也就是 Hopper 这一代上完成的。
But if your amount of watts is completely abundant, it's free, what do you care about performance per watt for? You get plenty. You can use old chips to do. So 7nm chips are essentially Hopper. The ability for Hopper… I've got to tell you, today's models are largely trained on Hopper, Hopper generation.
[Guest] 所以 7nm 芯片已经完全够用了。能源充足才是他们的优势。当然，接下来还有个问题，就是他们到底能不能真的造出足够多的芯片。但他们能。证据是什么？Huawei 刚刚创下了公司历史上最大的一年营收。他们到底出了多少芯片？非常多。几百万。几百万这个量，远远超过 Anthropic 手上的芯片数。
So 7nm chips are plenty good. The abundance of energy is their advantage. But then there's a question of whether they can actually manufacture enough chips. But they do. What's the evidence? Huawei just had the largest single year in the history of their company. How many chips did they ship? A ton. Millions. Millions is way more than Anthropic has.
[Host] 这里面有个问题，是 SMIC 到底能生产多少逻辑芯片，还有一个问题是内存能有多少——我告诉你实际情况是什么。他们的逻辑芯片很充足，HBM2 内存也很充足。对。但你也知道，在训练和推理这些模型时，瓶颈往往在带宽。所以如果你用的是 HBM2……我手头记不清具体数字了，但跟你们最新的东西相比，内存带宽可能会差接近一个数量级，这个差距是非常大的。Huawei 本来就是一家做网络的公司。但这并不能改变这样一个事实：
There's a question of how much logic SMIC can chip, and there's a question of how much memory— I'm telling you what it is. They have plenty of logic, and they have plenty of HBM2 memory. Right. But as you know, the bottleneck often in training and doing inference on these models is the amount of bandwidth. So if you have HBM2… I don't know the numbers offhand but versus the newest thing you have, there could be almost an order of magnitude difference in memory bandwidth, which is huge. Huawei is a networking company. But that doesn't change the fact
[Guest] 你说最先进的 HBM 一定需要 EUV。不是这样的，完全不是。可以把它们串联起来，就像我们用 NVL72 把它们连在一起一样。他们已经展示过 silicon photonics，把所有这些算力连接起来，组成一台巨型超级计算机。你的前提就是错的。事实是，他们的 AI 发展进展得很好。世界上最顶尖的 AI 研究人员，
that you need EUV for the most advanced HBM. Not true. Not at all true. You could gang them together, just like we gang them together with NVL72. They've already demonstrated silicon photonics, connecting all of this compute together into one giant supercomputer. Your premise is just wrong. The fact of the matter is, their AI development is going just fine. The best AI researchers in the world,
[Guest] 正因为他们的算力受限，反而也会想出非常聪明的算法。记住，我刚才说过，Moore's law 每年大概推进 25%。但通过出色的计算机科学，我们依然可以把算法性能提升 10 倍。我的意思是，真正的杠杆在优秀的计算机科学上。
because they're limited in compute, they also come up with extremely smart algorithms. Remember, I just said that Moore's law is advancing about 25% per year. However, through great computer science, we could still improve algorithm performance by 10x. What I'm saying is that great computer science is where the lever is.
[Guest] 毫无疑问，MoE 是一项伟大的发明。也毫无疑问，各种了不起的 attention 机制都在减少算力消耗。我们必须承认，AI 的大多数进步都来自算法进步，而不只是底层硬件本身。既然大多数进步都来自算法、计算机科学和编程，
There is no question, MoE is a great invention. There's no question, all the incredible attention mechanisms reduce the amount of compute. We have got to acknowledge that most of the advances in AI came out of algorithm advances, not just the raw hardware. Now, if most advances came from algorithms and computer science and programming,
[Guest] 那你告诉我，他们那支 AI 研究员大军怎么会不是他们最根本的优势。我们已经看到了。DeepSeek 绝不是一个无足轻重的进展。如果 DeepSeek 第一天先在 Huawei 上出来，那对我们国家来说就是非常糟糕的结果。为什么？因为现在像 DeepSeek 这样的模型，如果是开源的，就可以跑在任何加速器上。为什么未来这件事就不会继续成立？假设不会变。假设它就是为 Huawei 做了优化，假设它是为他们的架构专门优化的。
tell me that their army of AI researchers is not their fundamental advantage. We see it. DeepSeek is not an inconsequential advance. The day that DeepSeek comes out on Huawei first, that is a horrible outcome for our nation. Why is that? Because currently you can have a model like DeepSeek that can run on any accelerator, if it's open source. Why would that stop being the case in the future? Suppose it doesn’t. Suppose it's optimized for Huawei, suppose it's
[Host] 如果是为他们的架构优化的，那就会让我们的处于劣势。你描述的是一种在我看来反而算好消息的情况。一家公司开发了软件，开发了一个 AI 模型，而且它在美国的技术栈上跑得最好。我觉得这是好消息。可你把它设定成了一个坏消息的前提。那我来告诉你什么才是坏消息，
optimized for their architecture. It would put ours at a disadvantage. You described a situation that I perceive to be good news. A company developed software, developed an AI model, and it runs best on the American tech stack. I saw that as good news. You set it up as a premise that it was bad news. I'm going to give you the bad news,
[Host] 那就是全世界开发出来的 AI 模型，最后在非美国硬件上跑得最好。那对我们才是坏消息。我只是看不到有什么证据表明，差距大到会让你没法切换加速器。美国的实验室本来就在所有云平台、各种不同的加速器上跑他们的模型——我自己就是证据。你把一个为 Nvidia 优化的模型拿去跑在别的东西上试试。但美国实验室就是这么做的。
that AI models around the world are developed and they run best on non-American hardware. That is bad news for us. I guess I just don't see the evidence that there's these huge disparities that would prevent you from switching accelerators. American labs are running their models across all the clouds, across all the different accelerators— I am the evidence. You take a model that's optimized for Nvidia and you try to run it on something else. But American labs do that.
[Guest] 但它们跑得并没有更好。Nvidia 的成功就是最好的证据。AI 模型是在我们的技术栈上开发出来的，也是在我们的技术栈上跑得最好，这有什么难理解的？Anthropic 的模型会跑在 GPU 上，也会跑在 Trainium 上，还会跑在 TPU 上。要切过去得投入大量工作。但你去看看 global south，去看看中东。如果开箱即用时，所有 AI 模型在别人的技术栈上都跑得更好，那你现在居然还要硬说这对美国是好事，
And they don't run better. Nvidia's success is perfect evidence. The fact that AI models are created on our stack, run best on our stack, how is that illogical to understand? Anthropic's models are run on GPUs, they're run on Trainium, they're run on TPUs. A lot of work has to go into it to change. But go to the global south, go to the Middle East. Coming out of the box, if all of the AI models run best on somebody else's tech stack, you've
[Host] 那这个说法就太离谱了。但我还是不太明白你的论点。假设中国公司先做出了下一个 Mythos。他们先发现了美国软件里的所有安全漏洞，但他们可以在 Nvidia 硬件上做到这一点，然后把它卖到 global south。他们是在 Nvidia 硬件上做的。这怎么会是好事？好吧，它是跑在 Nvidia 硬件上—— 这不是好事。这不是好事。对，不是好事。所以我们就别让这种事发生。
got to be arguing some ridiculous claim right now that that's a good thing for the United States. But I guess I don't understand the argument. Say Chinese companies get to the next Mythos first. They find all the security vulnerabilities in American software first, but they can do it on Nvidia hardware and they ship it to the global south. They do it on Nvidia hardware. How is that good? Okay, it runs on Nvidia hardware— It's not good. It's not good. Right. It's not good. So let's not let it happen.
[Host] 你为什么觉得这东西是完全可替代的？也就是说，如果你不给他们提供算力，就会被 Huawei 原封不动地补上？他们是落后的，对吧？他们的芯片不如你们。这完全……现在就有证据。他们的芯片产业规模很大。你只要看看 H200 和 Huawei 910C 在 FLOPS、带宽或者内存上的对比就知道了。大概只有一半到三分之一。他们会用更多来补。他们会用两倍的数量。听起来你的论点是，他们已经有大量随时可用的能源，对吧？他们需要用芯片把这些能源填满。而且他们制造能力很强。我也相信，最终他们确实可能会靠制造规模压过所有人。但是中间有这几个关键年份。
Why do you think it's perfectly fungible, that if you didn't ship them compute it would exactly be replaced by Huawei? They are behind, right? They have worse chips than you. It's completely… There's evidence right now. Their chip industry's gigantic. You can just look at the flop or bandwidth or memory comparisons between the H200 and the Huawei 910C. It's like half to a third. They use more of it. They use twice as many. It seems like your argument is they have all this energy that's ready to go, right? And they need to fill it with chips. And they're good at manufacturing. And I'm sure eventually they would be
[Host] 你说的关键年份到底是哪几年？就是接下来的这几年。我们会有这些模型，它们将能够发动各种网络攻击。如果接下来几年这么关键，那我们就得确保，在这些关键年份里，全世界的 AI 模型都建立在美国技术栈之上。如果它们是建立在美国技术栈之上的，那如果它们具备了更先进的能力，这又怎么能阻止它们发动相当于 Mythos 的网络攻击呢？
able to just out-manufacture everybody. But there are these few critical years. What is the critical year you're talking about? These next few years. We've got these models that are going to be able to do all the cyber attacks. In that case, if the next years are critical, then we have to make sure that all of the world's AI models are built on the American tech stack, in these critical years. If they're built on the American tech stack, how would that prevent them, if they have more advanced capabilities, from launching
[Guest] 不管哪种情况，都没有保证。但如果你能更早拥有它，我们就可以提前做准备。听着，为什么你要让 AI 产业中的某一层失去整个市场，只为了让 AI 产业的另一层受益？这个产业有五层，而且每一层都必须成功。
the Mythos-equivalent cyber attacks? There's no guarantee either way. But if you have it early, we can prepare for it. Listen, why are you causing one layer of the AI industry to lose an entire market so that you could benefit another layer of the AI industry? There are five layers and every single layer has to succeed.
[Host] 真正最必须成功的那一层，其实是 AI 应用。你为什么这么执着于那个 AI 模型？那一家公司？到底为什么？因为这些模型会带来极其强大的进攻性能力，而运行它们需要算力。能源、芯片，以及 AI 研究人员的生态，才让这一切成为可能。几个月前，Jane Street 花了大约 2 万个 GPU 小时，在三个不同的语言模型里训练后门。
The layer that has to succeed most is actually the AI applications. Why are you so fixated on that AI model? That one company? For what reason? Because those models make possible these incredibly offensive capabilities, and you need compute to run them. The energy, the chips, and the ecosystem of AI researchers make it possible. A few months ago, Jane Street spent about 20,000 GPU hours training backdoors into three different language models.
[Host] 然后他们挑战我的观众去找出触发短语。我刚刚和设计这个谜题的 Ricson 聊过，谈了谈 Jane Street 收到的一些解法。"如果你把基础模型看作在这里，后门模型看作在那里，你某种程度上可以对权重做线性插值，来调整后门的强度；但你也可以继续外推，让后门变得更强。在某些情况下，如果你把它强化到足够强，模型就会直接把原本应该输出的响应短语原样吐出来。" 所以如果你不断放大基础版本和后门版本之间的差异，
Then they challenged my audience to find the trigger phrases. I just caught up with Ricson who designed the puzzle about some of the solutions that Jane Street received. “If you think the base model was here and the backdoor model was here, you can kind of linearly interpolate the weights to adjust the strength of the backdoor, but you can also extrapolate it to make the backdoor even stronger. And in some cases, if you make it strong enough the model will just regurgitate what the response phrase was supposed to be.” So if you keep amplifying the difference between
[Host] 最终它应该会直接吐出触发短语。但这个技术只在三个模型中的两个上奏效。就连 Ricson 也不确定，为什么在另一个模型上没成功。能够验证一个模型只会做你以为它会做的事，是 AI 安全里最重要的开放问题之一。如果这类问题让你兴奋，Jane Street 正在招聘研究员和工程师。去 janestreet.com/dwarkesh 了解更多。好，退一步说，中国肯定得有能力建出足够的 7nm 产能。
the base version and the backdoored version, eventually it should spit out the trigger phrase. But this technique only worked on two out of the three models. Even Ricson isn't sure why it didn't work on the other. Being able to verify that a model only does what you think it does is one of the most important open questions in AI security. If this is the kind of problem that excites you, Jane Street is hiring researchers and engineers. Go to janestreet.com/dwarkesh to learn more. Okay, stepping back, it has to be the case that China is able to build enough 7nm capacity.
[Guest] 别忘了，他们现在还卡在 7nm，而你们会继续推进到 3nm，然后是 2nm，或者借助 Feynman 到 1.6nm。所以当你们做到 1.6nm 的时候，他们还会停留在 7nm，而且他们必须生产出足够多的 7nm，来弥补这个缺口。他们有非常多的能源，所以你给他们越多芯片，他们就会拥有越多算力。所以归根结底，这就变成一个问题：他们最终拿到的是更多算力。算力是训练和推理的投入要素——听着，我只是觉得你说话太绝对了。
And remember, they're still stuck on 7nm while you'll move on to 3nm and then 2nm or 1.6nm with Feynman. So while you're on 1.6nm, they're still going to be on 7nm, and they have to produce enough of it to make up for the shortfall. They have so much energy that the more chips you give them, the more compute they'd have. So it comes out as a question of, ultimately they are getting more compute. Compute is an input to training and inference— Listen, I just think you speak in absolutes.
[Guest] 我认为美国应该保持领先。美国拥有的算力规模是世界其他任何地方的 100 倍。美国就应该领先。好。美国现在就是领先的。Nvidia 打造的是最先进的技术。我们会确保美国的实验室最先听到消息，也最先有机会购买。如果他们钱不够，我们甚至还会投资他们。美国就应该领先。我们想尽一切办法来确保
I think the United States ought to be ahead. The amount of compute in the United States is 100x more than anywhere else in the world. The United States ought to be ahead. Okay. The United States is ahead. Nvidia builds the most advanced technologies. We make sure that the US labs are the first to hear about it and have the first chance to buy it. And if they don't have enough money, we even invest in them. The United States ought to be ahead. We want to do everything we can to make
[Host] 当然，美国现在是领先的。第一点，你同意吗？我们正在尽一切努力保持这一点。但如果中国在算力上已经被卡住了，那把芯片运到中国，怎么还能让美国保持领先？不，不。我们给美国有 Vera Rubin。我们给美国有 Vera Rubin。那我是在美国吗？你觉得我算不算美国的一部分？算。Nvidia。你认为
sure the United States is ahead. Number one point, do you agree? We're doing everything we can to do that. But how is shipping chips to China keeping the US ahead if they’re bottlenecked on compute? No, no. We've got Vera Rubin for the United States. We have Vera Rubin for the United States. Now, am I in the United States? Do you consider me part of the United States? Yes. Nvidia. You consider
[Guest] Nvidia 是一家美国公司？好。第一，为什么我们不能制定一个更平衡的监管政策，让 Nvidia 能在全球取胜，而不是把全球市场拱手让出去？你为什么会希望美国把全球市场让出去？芯片产业是美国生态系统的一部分，是美国技术领导力的一部分，也是 AI 生态的一部分。它也是
Nvidia a United States company? Okay. Number one, why is it that we don't come up with a regulation that's more balanced so that Nvidia can win around the world instead of giving up the world? Why would you want the United States to give up the world? The chip industry is part of the American ecosystem. It's part of American technology leadership. It's part of the AI ecosystem. It's part of
[Host] AI 领导力的一部分。为什么你的政策、你的理念，会导致美国放弃全球市场中如此大的一块？我想这里的核心说法是……Dario 有句名言，大意是，这就像 Boeing 在吹嘘说我们在给朝鲜卖核武器，只不过导弹外壳是 Boeing 造的。而这居然还能算是在强化美国技术栈。从根本上说，你就是在给他们这种能力。把 AI 跟你刚才提到的那些东西相提并论，简直荒唐。
AI leadership. Why is it that your policy, your philosophy, leads to the United States giving up a vast part of the world's market? I guess the claim here is… Dario had this quote where he said that it's like Boeing bragging that we're selling North Korea nukes, but the missile casings are made by Boeing. And that's somehow enabling the US technology stack. Fundamentally, you're giving them this capability. Comparing AI to anything that you just mentioned is lunacy.
[Host] 但 AI 跟浓缩铀很像，不是吗？它可以有正面用途，也可以有负面用途。我们同样不希望把浓缩铀送到别的国家。谁在送浓缩——这个类比的意思是，浓缩铀就像算力。这个类比很糟糕，根本不合逻辑。但如果这种算力能跑出一个模型，对所有美国软件发动零日漏洞攻击，那它怎么就不算武器？
But AI is similar to enriched uranium, right? It can have positive uses, it can have negative uses. We still don't want to send enriched uranium to other countries. Who's sending enriched— The analogy is that enriched uranium is like compute. It's a lousy analogy. It's an illogical analogy. But if that compute can run a model that can do zero-day exploits against all American software, how is that not a weapon?
[Guest] 首先，解决这个问题的方式，是和研究人员对话，和中国对话，和所有国家对话，确保人们不会那样使用技术。这种对话必须发生，明白吗？这是第一。第二，我们也需要确保美国保持领先，让 Vera Rubin、Blackwell 在美国能够大量供应，堆成山那么多。
First of all, the way to solve that problem is to have dialogues with the researchers and dialogues with China, and dialogues with all the countries to make sure that people don't use technology in that way. That's a dialogue that has to happen. Okay? Number one. Number two, we also need to make sure that the United States is ahead, that Vera Rubin, Blackwell, is available in the United States in abundance, mountains of it.
[Guest] 显然，我们的结果就能说明这一点。要充足，大量充足。我们拥有的算力规模很可观。我们这里有非常出色的 AI 研究人员。这很好。我们应该继续保持领先。不过，我们也必须认识到，AI 不只是一个模型。AI 是一个五层蛋糕。AI 产业在每一层都很重要，而我们希望美国在每一层都能赢，包括芯片这一层。
Obviously, our results would show it. Abundance, tons of it. The amount of computing we have is great. We have amazing AI researchers here. It's great. We ought to stay ahead. However, we also have to recognize that AI is not just a model. AI is a five-layer cake. The AI industry matters across every single layer, and we want the United States to win at every single layer, including the chip layer.
[Host] 把整个市场都让出去，长期来看并不能让美国在芯片层、在计算技术栈上赢得技术竞赛。这就是事实。那我想关键问题就变成了：现在把芯片卖给他们，怎么能帮助我们长期取胜？Tesla 长期以来一直在向中国卖非常好的电动车。iPhone 也在中国卖，产品也非常好。但这并没有形成锁定。中国照样会做出他们自己的电动车，而且他们已经
Conceding the entire market is not going to allow the United States to win the technology race long-term in the chip layer, in the computing stack. That is just a fact. I guess then the crux comes down to, how does selling them chips now help us win in the long term? Tesla sold extremely good electric vehicles to China for a long time. iPhones are sold in China, extremely good. They didn't cause them lock-in. China will still make their version of EVs and they're
[Guest] 占据主导地位了。他们的智能手机也占据主导地位。我们今天一开始聊的时候，你也承认了，Nvidia 的处境非常不同。你用了“护城河”这样的词。对我们公司来说，最重要的一件事，就是我们生态系统的丰富度，而这说到底是开发者。50% 的 AI 开发者都在中国。美国不应该放弃这一点。但我们在美国也有很多 Nvidia 开发者，这并不妨碍
dominating. Their smartphones are dominating. When we started the conversation today, you acknowledged that Nvidia's position is very different. You used words like moat. The single most important thing to our company is the richness of our ecosystem, which is about developers. 50% of the AI developers are in China. The United States should not give that up. But we have a lot of Nvidia developers in the US, and that doesn't prevent
[Host] 也不会妨碍美国的实验室未来去使用其他加速器。事实上，他们现在也在用其他加速器，这很好，完全没问题。我看不出如果你把 Nvidia 芯片卖给中国，为什么中国那边就不能也是这样；就像 Google 既可以用 TPU，也可以用 Nvidia 一样——我们必须持续创新，而且你应该也知道，我们的份额是在增长，不是在下降。那种“就算我们在中国竞争，反正最后也会失去那个市场”的前提……
American labs from also being able to use other accelerators in the future. In fact, right now they're using other accelerators as well, which is fine and great. I don't see why that wouldn't be the case in China as well, if you sell them Nvidia chips, just the same way that Google can use TPUs and Nvidia— We have to keep innovating and, as you probably know, our share is growing, not decreasing. The premise that even if we competed in China,
[Guest] 你这是在跟一个不是一觉醒来就认输的人说话。那种失败者心态、失败者前提，在我看来根本说不通。我们不是汽车。我们不是汽车。今天买这个汽车品牌，明天换另一个汽车品牌，很容易。计算不是这样的。
that we're going to lose that market anyways… You're not talking to somebody who woke up a loser. That loser attitude, that loser premise makes no sense to me. We're not a car. We are not a car. The fact that I can buy this car brand one day and use another car brand another day, easy. Computing is not like that.
[Guest] x86 之所以能成气候是有原因的。ARM 之所以黏性这么强也是有原因的。这些生态系统都很难替代。要替换它们要花极其巨大的时间和精力，而且大多数人并不想这么做。所以我们的工作就是继续培育这个生态，继续推进技术进步，这样我们才能在市场上竞争。基于你刚才描述的那个前提，就把一个市场拱手让出去，我根本无法认同。
There's a reason why the x86 deal exists. There's a reason why ARM is so sticky. These ecosystems are hard to replace. It costs an enormous amount of time and energy, and most people don't want to do it. So it's our job to continue to nurture that ecosystem, to keep advancing the technology so that we can compete in the marketplace. Conceding a marketplace based on the premise you described, I simply can't
[Host] 我没法接受。这根本说不通。因为我不认为美国是个失败者。我们的产业也不是失败者。那种注定会输的论调、那种失败者思维，我完全不能理解。好吧，我继续往下说。我只是想确认一下——你不用继续往下说，我听得挺开心的。好，很好，那我就不往下了。谢谢你这么说。不过我觉得关键点可能在于……也谢谢你愿意陪我绕着这个问题来回讨论，因为我觉得这有助于把真正的关键点带出来。
acknowledge that. It makes no sense. Because I don't think the United States is a loser. Our industry is not a loser. That losing proposition, that losing mindset, makes no sense to me. Okay. I'll move on. I just want to make sure that— You don't have to move on. I'm enjoying it. Okay, great. Then I won't. I appreciate that. But I think maybe the crux… and thanks for walking around the circles with me, because I
[Guest] 我觉得这能帮助我们看清这里真正的关键。关键在于，你把问题推到了极端。你的论点是从极端情况出发的：好像只要我们在这个狭窄的时间窗口里给了他们任何一点算力，我们就会失去一切。不是，我觉得我的论点是——这些极端说法很幼稚。先让我自己把我的论点说完。我的意思不是说存在某个关键的算力门槛。我的意思是，任何边际算力都是有帮助的。所以如果你有更多算力，你就能训练出更好的模型。我只是希望你能承认——
think it helps bring out what the crux here is. The crux is you're going to extremes. Your argument starts from extremes. That if we give them any compute at all in this narrow moment, we will lose everything. No, I think what my argument is— Those extremes, they're childish. Let me just make my argument for myself. The idea is not that there is some key threshold of compute. It's that any marginal compute is helpful. So if you have more compute, you can train a better model. And I just want you to
[Guest] 对美国科技产业来说，任何边际销售都是有益的。其实我并不……如果运行在这些芯片上的 AI 模型具备网络攻击能力，或者这些芯片正在训练具备网络能力的模型，并运行更多这类模型实例，那它虽然不是核武器，但它确实在赋能某种武器。照你的逻辑，你也完全可以把同样的话用在微处理器和 DRAM 上。你甚至也可以把这话用在电力上。但事实上，我们确实对——
acknowledge that any marginal sales for the American technology industry is beneficial. I actually don't… If the AI models that run on those chips are capable of cyber offensive capabilities, or the chips are training models with cyber capabilities and running more instances of those models, it is not a nuclear weapon, but it enables a weapon of a kind. The logic that you use, you might as well say it to microprocessors and DRAMs. You might as well say it to electricity. But in fact we do have export controls
[Host] 那些与制造最先进 DRAM 相关的技术实施了出口管制。我们对中国各种芯片制造相关的东西都有很多出口管制。我们也向中国卖了很多 DRAM 和 CPU，我觉得这是对的。我想这又回到了那个根本问题：AI 是不是不一样？如果这类技术能让他们在软件里找到这些 zero-day 漏洞，那我们是不是应该尽量降低中国率先做到这一点、并大规模部署它的能力？我们希望美国保持领先。这个我们是可以控制的。
on the technology that is relevant to making the most advanced DRAM. We have all kinds of export controls on China for all kinds of chip-making stuff. We sell a lot of DRAM and CPUs into China, and I think it's right. I guess this goes back to the fundamental question of, is AI different? If you have the kind of technology where they can find these zero-days in software, is that something where we want to minimize China's ability to get there first, to deploy it widely? We want the United States to be ahead. We can control that.
[Host] 可如果芯片已经在那里了，而且他们正在用这些芯片训练那个模型，我们要怎么控制？我们有大量算力。我们有大量 AI 研究人员。我们正在以最快速度竞赛。再说一次，我们拥有的核武器比任何人都多，但我们也不会把浓缩铀送到任何地方去。我们不是浓缩铀。这是芯片，而且是他们自己也能造的芯片。但他们之所以从你们这里买，是有原因的。我们有中国公司创始人的原话，他们说自己的瓶颈就在算力上。因为我们的芯片更好。总体来说，我们的芯片就是更好。
How do we control that if the chips are already there and they're using them to train that model? We have tons of compute. We have tons of AI researchers. We're racing as fast as we can. Again, we have more nuclear weapons than anybody else, but we don't want to send enriched uranium anywhere. We're not enriched uranium. It's a chip, and it's a chip that they can make themselves. But there's a reason they're buying it from you. We have quotes from the founders of Chinese companies that say that they’re bottlenecked on compute. Because our chips are better. On balance, our chips are better.
[Guest] 这根本毫无疑问。没有我们的芯片……你能承认 Huawei 创下了历史最好的一年吗？你能承认有一大批芯片公司已经上市了吗？你能承认这一点吗？能。你也能承认，我们以前在那个市场占有非常大的份额，而现在已经不再有很大的份额了吗？我们也可以承认，中国大约占全球科技产业的 40%。把这个市场拱手让给美国科技
There's just no question about it. In the absence of our chip… Can you acknowledge that Huawei had a record year? Can you acknowledge that a whole bunch of chip companies have gone public? Can you acknowledge that? Yes. Can you also acknowledge that we used to have a very large share in that market, and we no longer have a large share in that market? We can also acknowledge that China is about 40% of the world's technology industry. To concede that market for the United States technology
[Host] 行业，是对我们国家的不负责任，是对国家安全的不负责任，也是对我们技术领导地位的不负责任，而这一切只是为了让一家公司受益。我实在想不通。我觉得我有点困惑。感觉你在说两件不同的事。一方面，你说如果允许我们竞争，我们就会靠更好的芯片在和 Huawei 的竞争中获胜。另一方面，你又说，就算没有我们，他们反正也会做完全一样的事。这两件事怎么可能同时都成立呢？
industry is a disservice to our country. It is a disservice to our national security. It is a disservice to our technology leadership, all for the benefit of one company. It makes no sense to me. I guess I'm confused. It feels like you're making two different statements. One is that we're going to win this competition with Huawei because our chips are going to be way better if we're allowed to compete. Another is that they would be doing the same exact thing without us anyway. How can both of those things be true at the same time?
[Guest] 这显然是成立的。没有更好的选择时，你就只能接受你唯一拥有的选择。这有什么不合逻辑的？这再合逻辑不过了。他们想要 Nvidia 的芯片，就是因为我们的更好。对。更好就意味着更强的算力。更强的算力就意味着你能训练出更好的模型。不，不只是这样。更好还因为它更容易编程。我们的生态系统也更好。但不管“更好”具体指什么，不管“更好”是什么……当然，我们会把算力送过去。那又怎样？事实就是，我们能从中受益。
It's obviously true. In the absence of a better choice, you'll take the only choice you have. How is that illogical? It's so logical. The reason they want Nvidia chips is that they're better. Yeah. Better is more compute. More compute means you can train a better model. No, it's just better. It's better because it's easier to program. We have a better ecosystem. But whatever the better is, whatever the better is… And of course we're going to send them compute. So what? The fact of the matter is that we get to benefit.
[Guest] 别忘了，我们能享受到美国技术领导地位带来的好处。我们能享受到开发者在美国技术栈上工作的好处。我们还能享受到这样一个好处：随着这些 AI 模型扩散到世界其他地方，美国技术栈也因此会成为最适合它们的选择。我们可以继续推进并传播美国技术。我认为这是件好事。这是美国技术领导力中非常重要的一部分。
Don't forget, we get the benefit of American technology leadership. We get the benefit of developers working on the American tech stack. We get the benefit, as those AI models diffuse out into the rest of the world, that the American tech stack is therefore the best for it. We can continue to advance and diffuse American technology. That, I believe, is a positive. It's a very important part of American technology leadership.
[Guest] 而你主张的这些政策，结果是把美国电信产业基本上用政策手段挤出了全球市场，到了我们连自己的通信都不再掌控的地步。我不觉得这很聪明。这种看法有点短视，而且带来了我现在正在跟你说的那些意想不到的后果，而你似乎很难理解。好吧，我们先退一步看。看起来这里的关键是，存在一种潜在的
Now, the policies that you're advocating resulted in the American telecommunications industry being policied out of basically the world, to the point where we don't control our own telecommunications anymore. I don't see that as smart. It's a little narrow-minded, and it led to unintended consequences that I'm describing to you right now that you seem to have a very hard time understanding. Okay, let's just step back. It seems like the crux here is there's a potential
[Host] 收益，也存在一种潜在的代价。我们现在想弄清楚的是，这个收益是否值得付出这个代价。我想我是在试着让你承认这种潜在代价。算力是训练强大模型的一种投入。强大的模型确实具备强大的进攻能力，比如网络攻击。美国公司先达到 Mythos 级别的能力，这是件好事；而且现在他们会暂时按住这些能力不公开，这样美国公司和美国政府就能在这种能力被公布之前，先把自己的软件防护做得更好。
benefit and there's a potential cost. What we're trying to figure out is, is the benefit worth the cost? I guess I'm trying to get you to acknowledge the potential cost. Compute is an input to training powerful models. Powerful models do have powerful offensive capabilities, like cyber attacks. It is a good thing that American companies got to Mythos-level capabilities first, and then now they're going to hold off on those capabilities so that the American companies and American government can make their software more protected before that level of capability was announced.
[Host] 如果中国当时拥有更多算力，或者更多众包算力，如果他们能更早做出一个 Mythos 级别的模型并广泛部署，那会非常糟糕。之所以没有发生，其中一个原因就是，得益于像 Nvidia 这样的美国公司，我们拥有更多算力。把这些送到中国去，这就是代价之一。所以先把收益放一边。你承认这是一种潜在代价吗？
If China had had more compute or more crowd compute, if they could have made a Mythos-level model earlier and deployed it widely, that would have been very bad. One of the reasons that hasn't happened is that we have more compute thanks to companies like Nvidia in America. That is a cost of sending it to China. So let's leave the benefit aside for a second. Do you acknowledge that this is a potential cost?
[Guest] 我也告诉你，潜在的代价还包括：我们让 AI 技术栈中最重要的层之一——芯片层——放弃了整个市场，也就是全球第二大市场；这样一来，他们就能做出规模，就能建立起自己的生态系统，结果未来的 AI 模型会以一种与美国技术栈非常不同的方式来做优化。
I'll also tell you the potential cost is we allow one of the most important layers of the AI stack, the chip layer, to concede an entire market—the second largest market in the world—so that they could develop scale, so that they could develop their own ecosystem, so that future AI models are optimized in a very different way than the American tech stack.
[Host] 随着 AI 向世界其他地方扩散，他们的标准、他们的技术栈会变得比我们更强，因为他们的模型是开放的。我想我还是足够相信 Nvidia 的内核工程师和 CUDA 工程师，觉得他们是能做优化的——当然，你也知道，AI 不只是内核优化。没错，但你能做的事情还有很多，比如蒸馏出更适配你们芯片的模型。我们会尽最大努力。你们拥有整套软件。只是很难想象，长期来看中国生态会形成什么锁定效应，哪怕他们暂时有一个稍微更好的开源模型。
As AI diffuses out into the rest of the world, their standards, their tech stack, will become superior to ours, because their models are open. I guess I just believe enough in Nvidia's kernel engineers and CUDA engineers to think that they could optimize— AI is more than kernel optimization, as you know. Of course, but there are so many things you can do, from distilling to a model that's well-fit for your chips. We're going to do our best. You have all the software. It's just hard to imagine that there's a long-term lock-in to the Chinese ecosystem, even if they have a
[Guest] 中国是全球开源软件最大的贡献者。这是事实。中国也是全球开放模型最大的贡献者。这也是事实。今天这一切还是建立在美国的技术栈之上，也就是 Nvidia 的。这同样是事实。AI 技术栈的五个层级都很重要。美国应该把这五层全都赢下来。
slightly better open source model for a while. China is the largest contributor to open source software in the world. Fact. China's the largest contributor to open models in the world. Fact. Today it's built on the American tech stack, Nvidia’s. Fact. All five layers of the tech stack for AI are important. The United States ought to go win all five of
[Guest] 它们每一层都很重要。当然，其中最重要的是 AI 应用层。真正渗透进社会的那一层，谁用得最多，谁就会从这场工业革命中获益最多。但我的观点是，每一层都必须成功。如果我们把这个国家吓得觉得 AI somehow 像核弹一样，搞得所有人都讨厌 AI、害怕 AI，我不知道这对美国有什么帮助。这是在帮倒忙。
them. They're all important. The one that is the most important, of course, is the AI application layer. The layer that diffuses into society, the one that uses it most will benefit from this industrial revolution most. But my point is that every layer has to succeed. If we scare this country into thinking that AI is
[Guest] 如果我们把大家都吓得不敢去做软件工程工作，因为 AI 会杀死所有软件工程岗位——结果就是我们最后根本没有软件工程师——那我们就是在伤害美国。如果我们把大家都吓得不敢学放射科，搞得没人想当放射科医生，因为计算机视觉几乎免费，而且任何 AI 都不会比放射科医生做得更差，那就是我们根本没搞清楚“工作”和“任务”的区别。
somehow a nuclear bomb, so that everybody hates AI and everybody's afraid of AI, I don't know how you're helping the United States. You're doing it a disservice. If we scare everybody out of doing software engineering jobs because it's going to kill every software engineering job—and we don't have any software engineers as a result of that—we're doing a disservice to the United States. If we scare everybody out of radiology so
[Guest] 放射科医生的工作是照护病人，读片只是其中一项任务。如果我们连这一点都严重误解，还把所有人都吓得不去读放射科，那我们最后就会没有足够的放射科医生，也不会有足够好的医疗服务。
nobody wants to be a radiologist because computer vision is completely free and no AI is going to do a worse job than a radiologist, we misunderstand the difference between a job and a task. The job of a radiologist is patient care. The task is to read a scan. If we misunderstand that so profoundly and we scare everybody out of going to radiology school, we're not going to have enough radiologists and good enough healthcare.
[Guest] 所以我想表达的是，一旦你的前提设定得过于极端，所有事情都会被说成不是零就是无穷大，最后我们就会用一种并不真实的方式把人吓住。现实生活不是这样的。
So I'm making the case that when you make a premise that is so extreme, everything goes from zero or infinity, we end up scaring people in a way that's just not true. Life is not like
[Guest] 我们希望美国排第一吗？当然希望。我们需要在这套技术栈的每一层都成为领导者吗？当然需要，当然需要。今天你在谈 Mythos，因为 Mythos 很重要。没错，这很好。但我现在就给你一个预测：再过几年，当我们希望美国技术栈、美国技术扩散到全世界——扩散到 India、扩散到 Middle East、扩散到 Africa、扩散到 Southeast Asia——的时候，
that. Do we want the United States to be first? Of course we do. Do we need to be a leader in every layer of that stack? Of course we do. Of course we do. Today you're talking about Mythos because Mythos is important. Sure. That's fantastic. But in a few years time, I'm making you the prediction
[Guest] 当我们的国家想要出口，因为我们想出口我们的技术，也想出口我们的标准，到那一天，我希望你和我能再来进行同样的一次对话。到时候我会原原本本地跟你讲今天这场对话，讲你的政策是如何
that when we want the American tech stack, when we want American technology to be diffused around the world—out to India, out to the Middle East, out to Africa, out to Southeast Asia—when our country would like to export, because we would like to export our technology, we would like to export our standards, on that day, I want you and I to have that same conversation again. I will tell you exactly about today's conversation, about how your policy
[Guest] 而你设想的那套做法，实际上让美国毫无道理地把全球第二大市场拱手让了出去。我们不该主动放弃它。要是最后真丢了，那是另一回事；但为什么要自己先让出去？现在也没人主张非黑即白。没人主张“全有或全无”，也不是说任何时候都把所有东西往 China 运。没人这么主张。我们当然应该始终把最好的技术留在本土。
and what you imagined literally caused the United States to concede the second largest market in the world for no good reason at all. We shouldn't concede it. If we lose it, we lose it. But why do we concede it? Now nobody is advocating an all or nothing. Nobody's advocating all or nothing, meaning we ship everything to China at all times. Nobody's advocating that. We should always have the best technology here.
[Guest] 我们也应该始终把最多、最先进的技术先放在本土。但与此同时，我们也应该努力在全球范围内竞争并取胜。这两件事完全可以同时做到。这需要一些细致判断，需要一些成熟度，而不是搞绝对化。世界本来就不是非黑即白。好，争论的关键就在这里。他们建立的模型，针对的是他们未来几年能做出来的最好芯片。
We should always have the most technology here, and the first. But we should also try to compete and win around the world. Both of those things can simultaneously happen. It requires some amount of nuance, some amount of maturity instead of absolutes. The world is just not absolutes. Okay. The argument hinges on this. They've built models that are specified for the
[Host] 这些芯片会出口到全世界。那样一来，它们就会成为标准。正如我们刚才说的，因为 EUV 出口管制，你们会继续推进到 1.6nm。而他们即便再过几年，可能还停留在 7nm。就国内使用来说，他们也许会觉得这很合理：‘我们能源很多，可以大规模制造，那就继续用 7nm。’但说到出口，他们的 7nm 芯片就必须能和你的 1.6nm 芯片竞争。他们的模型必须针对
best chips that they make in a few years. Those chips get exported around the world. That sets the standard. Because of EUV export controls, as we said, you're going to move on to 1.6nm. They're still going to be on 7nm, even after a few years from now. It may make sense that domestically they would prefer, "Hey, we've got so much energy, we can manufacture at scale. We'll still keep using 7nm." But on the exporting thing, their 7nm chips have to be competitive against your 1.6nm chips. Their models have to be so far optimized for
[Host] 7nm 做到极致优化，优化到一个程度：跑在他们的 7nm 上，比跑在你们的 1.6nm 上还更好。那我们就看事实吧。Blackwell 的先进光刻水平比 Hopper 高 50 倍吗？有 50 倍吗？根本差得远。我一直在反复说这件事。摩尔定律已经死了。单看晶体管本身，从 Hopper 到 Blackwell，算 75% 吧。
the 7nm that it's better to run their models on 7nm than to run their models on your 1.6nm. Can we just look at the facts then? Is Blackwell 50 times more advanced lithography than Hopper? Is it 50 times? Not even close. I just kept saying it over and over again. Moore's Law is dead. Between Hopper and Blackwell, from the transistors themselves, call it 75%.
[Guest] 它们相隔三年，提升是 75%。但 Blackwell 相比 Hopper 的整体表现是 50 倍。我的意思是，架构很重要。计算机科学很重要。半导体物理当然也重要，但计算机科学同样重要。AI 的影响力，很大程度上来自计算栈，
It was three years apart, 75%. Blackwell is 50 times Hopper. My point is, architecture matters. Computer science matters. Semiconductor physics matters as well, but computer science matters. The impact of AI largely comes from the computing stack,
[Guest] 这也是为什么 CUDA 这么有效，为什么 CUDA 这么受欢迎。它是一个生态系统，是一种计算架构，提供了极大的灵活性。你如果想彻底改变架构——比如做 MoE，做 diffusion，或者做某种解耦式的东西——你都可以做到，而且很容易。所以现实情况是，AI 不仅仅关乎底层架构，
which is the reason why CUDA is so effective, which is the reason why CUDA is so beloved. It's an ecosystem, a computing architecture that allows for so much flexibility that if you wanted to change an architecture completely—create something like MoE, create something like diffusion, create something that's disaggregated—you could do so. It's easy to do. So the fact of the matter is, AI is about the stack above as much
[Guest] 同样也关乎上层的软件栈。只要我们的架构和软件栈是围绕我们自己的栈、我们自己的生态来优化的，那显然是好事，因为我们今天一开始就在谈 Nvidia 的生态有多丰富。为什么大家总是最喜欢先用 CUDA 编程？事实就是如此。China 的研究人员也是这样。
as it is about the architecture below. To the extent that we have architectures and software stacks that are optimized for our stack, for our ecosystem, it is obviously good, because we started the conversation today about how Nvidia's ecosystem is so rich. Why do people always love programming CUDA first? They do. They do. So do the researchers in China.
[Guest] 但如果我们被迫离开 China，如果我们被迫退出 China，首先，这就是一个政策错误。显然它会带来反噬。结果也证明，这对美国并不好。它让他们的芯片产业得到了助推、被加速发展。它还迫使他们整个 AI 生态都把重心放在
But if we are forced to leave China, if we're forced to leave China, first of all, it's a policy mistake. Obviously it has backlash. It has turned out badly for the United States. It enabled, it accelerated their chip industry. It forced all of their AI ecosystem to focus on
[Guest] 它们的内部架构。现在还不算太晚，不过这件事终究已经发生了。未来你会看到，它们显然不会被卡在 7nm。它们的制造能力很强，会继续从 7nm 往更先进的节点推进。那 5nm 和 7nm 之间有 10 倍差距吗——
their internal architectures. It's not too late, but nonetheless it has already happened. You're going to see in the future, they're not stuck at 7nm, obviously. They're good at manufacturing. They will continue to advance from 7nm and beyond. Now, is there a 10x difference between 5nm and
[Host] 答案是没有。架构很重要，网络也很重要。这也是为什么 Nvidia 收购了 Mellanox。网络很重要，能耗也很重要。所以这些东西都很重要。事情没你想提炼得那么简单。我们可以先不聊中国，但这其实引出了一个挺有意思的问题。我们刚才在聊 TSMC、内存之类的瓶颈。所以如果我们处在这样一个世界里：你已经吃下了 N3 的大部分产能——而且在某个时候，到了 N2，你也会占到大头——那么你会不会回过头去用 N7，利用老制程节点上的剩余产能，然后说："AI 的需求实在太大了，而我们扩充最先进制程产能的速度跟不上，所以我们要做一个 Hopper 或者 Ampere，
7nm? The answer is no. Architecture matters. Networking matters. That's why Nvidia bought Mellanox. Networking matters. Energy matters. So all of that stuff matters. It's not simplistic, like the way you're trying to distill it. We can move on from China, but that actually raises an interesting question. We were discussing earlier these bottlenecks at TSMC and memory and so forth. So if we're in this world where you're already the majority of N3—and at some
[Host] 但结合我们今天对数值计算的所有认知，以及你刚才提到的其他各种改进"？你觉得这种情况会在 2030 年之前发生吗？其实没这个必要。原因是——
point you'll be N2 and you'll be a majority of that—do you see that you could go back to N7, the spare capacity at an older process node, and say, "Hey, the demand for AI is so great and our capacity to expand the leading edge is not meeting it, so we're going to make a Hopper or Ampere, but with everything we know about numerics today and all the other improvements you described"? Do you see that world happening before 2030? It's not necessary to. The reason for that is
[Guest] 因为每一代产品，架构提升都不只是晶体管尺度上的变化。你还在做大量工程工作，包括封装、堆叠、数值计算，还有系统架构。等你产能不够的时候，
because with every generation, the architecture is more than just the transistor scale. You're doing so much engineering and packaging and stacking, and the numerics and the system architecture. When you run out of capacity,
[Guest] 想轻松退回去用另一个制程节点……那需要投入的研发规模是谁都负担不起的。我们可以负担得起继续往前冲，但我不觉得我们负担得起往回走。当然，如果这个世界真的说……我们做个思想实验吧，如果到了那一天，我们说："听着，我们以后就是再也不会有更多产能了。"那我会不会回去用 7nm？我会，毫不犹豫，当然会。
to easily go back to another node… That's a level of R&D that no one could afford. We could afford to lean forward. I don't think we could afford to go back. Now, if the world simply says… If on that day, let's do the thought experiment, on that day we go, "Listen, we're just never going to have more capacity ever again." Would I go back and use 7nm? In a heartbeat, of course I would.
[Host] 我之前聊过的一个人有个问题：为什么 Nvidia 不同时推进多个完全不同架构的芯片项目？比如你可以做一个像 Cerebras 那样的晶圆级方案，也可以做一个像 Dojo 那样的超大封装。你还可以做一个不带 CUDA 的方案。你们有资源，也有工程人才，可以把这些方向并行推进。那既然谁也不知道 AI 会往哪走、架构会往哪走，为什么要把鸡蛋都放在一个篮子里？哦，我们当然可以。只是——
One question somebody I was talking to had is, why doesn't Nvidia run multiple different chip projects at the same time with totally different architecture? So you could do something like a Cerebras-style wafer scale. You could do a Dojo-style huge package. You could do one without CUDA. You have the resources and the engineering talent to do all of these in parallel. So why put all the eggs in one basket, given who knows where AI might go and architectures might go? Oh, we could. It's just
[Guest] 只是我们没有更好的想法。那些事我们都能做，只是并不会更好。我们会在模拟器里把这些方案全都模拟一遍，结果可以证明它们更差。所以我们不会去做。我们现在做的，正是我们想做的那些项目。
that we don't have a better idea. We could do all of those things. It's just not better. We simulate it all in our simulator, proveably worse. So we wouldn't do it. We're working on exactly the projects that we want to work on.
[Guest] 如果工作负载发生巨大变化——我说的不是算法变化，我说的真的是工作负载，而这又取决于市场形态——那我们可能会决定加入其他加速器。比如最近我们就加入了 Groq，而且我们会把 Groq 纳入我们的 CUDA 生态系统。
If the workload were to change dramatically—and I don't mean the algorithms, I actually mean the workload, and that depends on the shape of the market—we may decide to add other accelerators. For example, recently we added Groq, and we're going to fold Groq into our CUDA ecosystem.
[Guest] 我们现在这么做，是因为 token 的价值已经高到可以做差异化定价了。早些年，也就是两三年前，token 不是免费的，就是几乎不值钱。但现在你会有不同类型的客户，而这些客户想要不同的答案。因为客户能赚很多钱——比如说我们的软件工程师——如果我能给他们响应快得多的 token，让他们比今天更高效，我是愿意为此付费的。
We're doing that now because the value of tokens has gone up so high that you could have different pricing of tokens. Back in the old days, just a couple years ago, tokens were either free or barely expensive. But now you can have different customers, and those customers want different answers. Because the customers make so much money—for
[Guest] 比如说，我们的软件工程师——如果我能给他们响应更快的 token，让他们比现在更高效，我愿意付这个钱。但这个市场其实是最近才出现的。所以我觉得，现在我们已经有能力让同一个模型，基于响应时间，做出不同的细分市场。
example, our software engineers—if I can give them much more responsive tokens so that they're even more productive than they are today, I would pay for it. But that market has only recently emerged. So I think we now have the ability to have the same model, based on the response time, have different segments.
[Guest] 这就是为什么我们决定去扩展 Pareto frontier，做出一个响应时间更快的推理细分，哪怕它的吞吐量更低。过去一直都是吞吐量越高越好。我们认为，未来可能会出现一种情况：token 的 ASP 会非常高，即使在
That's the reason why we decided to expand the Pareto frontier and create a segment of inference that is faster response time, even though it's lower throughput. Until now, higher throughput is always better. We think there could be a world where there could be very high ASP tokens, and even though the throughput is lower in the
[Guest] 工厂里的吞吐量更低，ASP 也足以把这部分补回来。这就是我们这么做的原因。不过除此之外，从架构角度看，如果我有更多钱，我会更多投到 Nvidia 的架构上。我觉得这种“极高端 token”以及推理市场进一步拆分的想法非常有意思。就是这个市场的分层。对。好，最后一个问题。假设深度
factory, the ASPs make up for it. That's the reason why we did it. But otherwise, from an architecture perspective, if I had more money, I would put more behind Nvidia’s architecture. I think this idea of extremely premium tokens and just the disaggregation of the inference market is a very interesting. The segmentation of it. Yeah. Alright, final question. Suppose the deep
[Host] 学习革命没有发生，Nvidia 会在做什么？显然游戏还是会做，但除此之外——加速计算，还是我们一直在做的那件事。我们公司的基本判断是，Moore's law 终究会……通用计算很多事情都能做，但对很多计算任务来说，它并不是理想方案。
learning revolution didn't happen. What would Nvidia be doing? Obviously games, but given— Accelerated computing, the same thing we've been doing all along. The premise of our company is that Moore's law is going to… General purpose computing is good for a lot of things, but for a lot of computation it's not ideal.
[Guest] 所以我们把一种叫 GPU 的架构、CUDA，和 CPU 结合起来，这样就能加速 CPU 的工作负载。不同的代码 kernel 或算法都可以卸载到我们的 GPU 上。结果就是，一个应用可以提速 100 倍、200 倍。这能用在哪儿？显然可以用在工程、科学、物理这些领域，
So we combined an architecture called a GPU, CUDA, to a CPU, so that we can accelerate the workload of the CPU. Different kernels of code or algorithms could be offloaded onto our GPU. As a result, you speed up an application by 100x, 200x. Where can you use that? Obviously engineering and science and physics,
[Guest] 数据处理、计算机图形、图像生成，各种各样的场景。即使今天 AI 不存在，Nvidia 也会是一家非常非常大的公司。原因其实很根本：通用计算继续扩展性能的能力，基本上已经走到头了。而实现这一点的方式……也不能说是唯一方式，但其中一种方式就是
data processing, computer graphics, image generation, all kinds of things. Even if AI doesn't exist today, Nvidia would be very, very large. The reason for that is fairly fundamental, which is that the ability for general purpose computing to continue to scale has largely run its course. And the only way… Not the only way, but the way to
[Guest] 通过领域专用加速。我们最早切入的领域之一是计算机图形，但其实还有很多别的领域，多得很。像粒子物理、流体、结构化数据处理，各种不同类型的算法都能从 CUDA 中受益。我们的使命其实就是把加速计算带到
do that is through domain-specific acceleration. One of the domains that we started with was computer graphics, but there are many other domains. There's all kinds. Particle physics and fluids, structured data processing, all kinds of different types of algorithms that benefit from CUDA. Our mission was really to bring accelerated
[Guest] 把计算能力带给全世界，并推动那些通用计算做不到的应用类型发展，把能力扩展到足以帮助某些科学领域实现突破的水平。早期的一些应用包括分子动力学、用于能源勘探的地震处理，当然还有图像处理，凡是这类通用计算根本效率太低的领域，都是如此。
computing to the world and advance the type of applications that general purpose computing can't do, and scale to the level of capability that helps break through certain fields of science. Some of the early applications were molecular dynamics, seismic processing for energy discovery, image processing of course, all of those kinds of fields where general purpose computing
[Guest] 通用计算做这些事就是太低效了。如果没有 AI，我会非常难过。但正因为我们在计算方面取得了进展，我们把深度学习普及开来了。我们让任何研究人员、任何科学家、任何地方的任何学生，都能够用上一台 PC 或一块 GeForce 插卡，做出令人惊叹的科学成果。
is just simply too inefficient to do so. If there were no AI, I would be very sad. But because of the advances that we made in computing, we democratized deep learning. We made it possible for any researcher, any scientist, anywhere, any student, to be able to access a PC or a GeForce add-in card and do amazing science.
[Guest] 这个最根本的承诺从来没有变过，一点都没有。如果你看 GTC，开头有很大一部分内容，完全不是 AI。那一整部分，无论是计算光刻、我们的量子化学工作，还是数据处理方面的工作，这些东西都
That fundamental promise hasn't changed, not even a little bit. If you watch GTC, there's the whole beginning part of it. None of it's AI. That whole part of it with computational lithography or our quantum chemistry work, data processing work, all of that stuff is
[Guest] 和 AI 无关。但它们依然非常重要。我知道 AI 很有意思，也确实很令人兴奋，但还有很多人在做大量非常重要、却和 AI 无关的工作，而且张量也不是唯一的计算方式。我们希望帮助每一个人。Jensen，太感谢你了。不客气。我聊得很开心。我也是。
unrelated to AI. And it's still very important. I know that AI is very interesting and quite exciting, but there's a lot of people doing a lot of very important work that's not AI related, and tensors are not the only way that you compute it. We want to help everybody. Jensen, thank you so much. You're welcome. I enjoyed it. Me too.